household um leas leasehold housing
stock however this is supposed to read
members request of the head of property
to attend a future GNA committee to
discuss the process of generating income
with the council's portfolio of property
that wasn't specific to housing um so
that is it in terms of discussion on uh
amendments from the minutes from July um
I will propose that we accept these uh
minutes uh can I have a second please
councelor Pacman do members
agree thank you very
much okay uh point of information um
Chris blendell has sent a uh a uh email
out about this but members are asked to
note that you need to approve the uh
minutes and fall now just propose on a
second because you've uh approved the
Amendments but okay yeah apologies
before we move on then uh so that was
for the Amendments um I'll propose that
we adopt the minutes themselves as well
as the Amendments could have a second of
councelor Pacman again are we agreed
thank you um so yes point of information
members are asked to note that items 13
and 14 have been removed from discussion
from tonight's uh meeting and we brought
back to members at a date um still to be
arranged for an extraordinary meeting
likely to be in January so I'm sure
you're all excitedly thinking of coming
out in January for a cyber security
specific GNA meeting um I certainly will
be um but details and dates of that will
be coming out um people are also asked
to note that items 9 11 will be
discussed after item 10 but actually I
think that note uh doesn't isn't
relevant now so apologies um agenda item
four treasury management strategy
statement minimum review uh re minimum
Revenue provision policy statement
annual investment strategy for
20242 Matt would you like to speak on
this rolls off the tongue doesn't it
this report and annexes include the
proposed treasury management strategy
statement minimum Revenue provision
policy statement annual investment
strategy Capital strategy and non-t
treasury Investments report the tmss for
2425 treasury management is the
management of the council's cash flows
is banking money market and Capital
Market transactions the effective
control of the risk associated with
those activities and the pursuit of
optimum performance consistent with
those risks every year we invest and
borrow money in order to manage the
council's fluctuating cash flow these
activities are undertaken in accordance
with strict criteria that complies with
statutary guidance and Council approving
limits this report is therefore
important in the in that respect as it
provides the capital plans including
credential indicators a minimum Revenue
provision or MRP policy that indicates
how residual capital expenditure is
charged to the revenue over time the
treasury management strategy which is
how the Investments and borrowings are
to be organized including treasury
indicators and an investment strategy
the parameters on how Investments are to
be managed key reporting items to
consider which have been included R the
port are capital expenditure of 134
million is forecast over the next 3
years for 2425 to 2627 inclusive
requiring borrowing of 34.5 million
there has been no change to the minimum
Revenue provision policy policy for
paying off the accumulated borrowing
requirement it is recommended that the
governance audit committee notes and
makes any comments on as appropriate to
this report and annexes including each
of the key elements listed these
includes the capital plans credential
indicators and Lim for 2425 to 2627
including the authorized limit
credential indicator the minimum Revenue
provision policy the treasury management
strategy for 2425 to 2627 and the
treasury indicators the investment
strategy for 2425 contained in the
treasury management strategy including
the detailed criteria and the capital
strategy for 2425 and the non-t treasury
Investments report for 2525
2425 and finally that this committee
recommends this report and annexes
including each of the key elements
listed in the report to council for
approval thank you thank you very much
Matt we don't have anyone speaking under
Council rules um do we have any
questions or comments from
Members so this agenda item is down to
note and to recommend the council can I
have a proposal please councel Donaldson
and a
seconder councelor Brer thank you very
much are we
agreed thank you very much members okay
agenda item five midyear review 2324
treasury management and annual invest M
strategy Matt can you please introduce
the report thank you chair similar to
the report previously this report
summarizes treasury management activity
and potential and treasury indicators
for the first half of
2324 the previous report and
introduction covered why and how we do
what we do with regards to treasury this
report covers where we are at the
midpoint for 23 24 with regards to key
indicators and as a result the following
represents the key reporting items to
consider for 2324 midyear capital
expenditure on long-term assets was 5.9
million 2223 midyear 6.3 million against
a full year budget of 60 million this is
mainly due this underspend in case you
was wondering is mainly due to general
fund projects that include housing
assistance policy office accommodation
uh broadstairs flood and Coast
protection Westbrook to St mre's Bay
that is it also represents the
additional allocation for HRA schemes in
terms of uh Acquisitions and new build
program which was increased during the
course of the year and subsequently a
large chunk nearly 26 24 million of that
uh variance is particular to the um HRA
the council's gross debt also called the
borrowing position at the 30th of
September 2023 was 19.7 Million as at
the 30th of September 22 it was 20
million so as you can see they in line
the council's underlying need to borrow
to finance his capital expenditure also
called the capital financing requirement
is estimated to be 78.3 million at the
31st of March 24 as at the 31st of March
23 it was 52.2 Million that movement is
predominantly due to the increase in HRA
that I just
mentioned the council has held less
gross debt than its capital financing
requirement and accordingly has complied
with the requirement not to exceed its
authorized borrowing limit of 81 million
as at the 30th of September 2023 the
council's Investments balances were 55.4
million as at the same time last year it
was 56.8 so as you can see again very
similar
it is proposed that the 2324 treasury
management strategy statement be amended
as described in section three of the
report this being that both the
operational boundary and authorized
limit for borrowing in 2324 treasury
management strategy as referred to in
section 3.1 of the report be increased
by 20 million to reflect the increase in
2324 HRA Capital program for the
acquisition and development of new
affordable housing units and finally and
as previously that this is this
committee recommends this report and
annexes including each of the key
elements listed in the report to council
for approval thank you
chair thank you very much uh do any
members have any comments or questions
yep councelor
to you know all the boring that we're
going through and going forward I mean
what are the rates that we're currently
paying for the boring uh for you know
throughout the next uh two years that
you're negotiating
currently it depends depends on the
length of term of the borrowing so we
get preferential rates through the
Public Works loan board so whatever the
market rates are we effectively borrow
at a slightly lower rate than that it's
1.25 I think below the market rate
effectively for
pwb yeah map's correct so we get a
preferential rate as local authorities
typically can borrow a lower interest
rate than um commercial
Enterprises uh as M rightly said again
depends on the term so for us at the
moment um we can if we were to borrow
for up to 50 years we go about 5% so
you'd have to lock in 5% for 50 years
given that we think interest rates are
going to go down um in the sort of
medium-term at least that's not
something we'd be looking to do um but
if you were looking to borrow for a year
we'd still be looking at getting five
5.5% which is just marginally above base
right at the moment but better than you
get out on on the commercial
markets any other me members have any
comments or questions um so this is down
for noting and then recommending to
Council for approval can I have a
proposal and a second please sorry CH
yeah of course um just um just a little
bit further uh detail on this sport just
wanted to sort of explain that um you
and I met to um answer some questions um
around um just not necessarily these
reports but our treasury management um
uh strategy um approach in general
treasury management I appreciate it's a
very dry subject but it is something
that is important um it's one of the
things that you'll see at Lo authorities
when they've gone wrong uh there's been
another Authority that's just gone into
a section 114 notice territory today
although that's not treasury management
related it's Nottingham City Council who
had Robin Hood energy was one of the
things that's been pinned on that um
other authorities have got themselves
into a bind a lot of it has been around
bad Investments we are I would say and
the the strategy Matt presented earlier
is a uh relatively lowrisk um strategy
there's nothing that I have to present
to you as the committee either in this
report the preceding report that would
be I would say raise any alarm Bells
these are the things that um committee
should have in mind if they've got
questions thank you Chris and the the
purpose of the meeting was I wanted to
understand the council's debt position
and the position of our reserves with uh
reference to the risk register and how
the council would deal with um risks
emerging or impacting the council and
where we would have the the cash
reserves and the ability to respond to
that and I feel much more assured from
having that time all of the details were
shared with me are in the report um and
um I do have a question on this and I
was going to bring it up under the risk
reg as we're as we're talking about it
um two of the risks that we're talking
around are around uh limited resources
for the council and uh the economic
environment um without going into the
politics of it um how do you think the
Autumn statement may change sort of the
medium term projection for the council
in terms of central government support
bearing in mind that the Autumn
statement includes quite large cuts to
um significant departments and has been
accepted I Believe by both political
parties um yeah good questions um the
autn statement doesn't give detail to
local authorities so we'll get the
detail in the local government uh
provisional Finance settlement which
will come forward U be announced and
published probably just before Christmas
break um
um we're not expecting there to be any
further um significant allocations for
for local government over and above
what's already been announced there
wasn't much in the Autumn statement in
terms of detail uh or further funding
allocations much of that was set out in
the previous spending review
um I don't want to talk too much in
terms of where other local authorities
are clearly there stuff in the press
that you you will have read other um
commentators uh opinions on the overall
health of the sector for than we're in a
reasonbly good place um I'm um I'm in
terms of our financial position at the
moment and although there wasn't any
good news in the um Autumn statement in
terms of additional funding we still are
on a relatively short
footing thank you very much any more
comments or questions from Members no so
as I said before this is down for noting
and recommend ending to council for
approval can I have a proposal and a
second
please councelor Pacman propos and
councel Donaldson seconded are members
agreed thank you very much okay agenda
item six contract standing order waivers
Chris can you please provid us with your
report thank you chair so uh this is uh
I believe the fourth of um such reports
that have come to the committee
previously the purpose of this report
ultimately is to provide um a
transparent picture of what uh is uh
going on in terms of the council's
procuring and purchasing activity and in
particular where there's been deviations
from our standard practices so you'll
see in here uh reference to our contract
standing orders they're effective by our
rules it's just a it's a fancy way of
saying the rules in terms of how we need
to to buy things at the authority in
certain instances we will wave the rules
which means we don't follow exactly
what's written down on the rules but
it's got to be for a good reason um
there are certain instances where we
can't wave those rules and that would
depend on the value of those contracts
so if you're into higher value contracts
and as you'll see on the table on the
first page in the executive summary if
we're looking at the procurement of um
good Supply or Services anything over £
178,000 we have to follow the rules
because that's set in legislation below
that there what we refer to as our local
rules good practice that we need to
follow when we uh require our services
to to follow those rules in order to um
get best value for money in our
purchasing activity however there are
some instances where we deem it's best
to deviate from those uh rules in order
to get best value for the uh Council and
that's the purposes report so it sets
out where we have deviated from those
those rules so you'll see in the table
again just in the executive summary
there have been um 12 and es between
July uh to uh the beginning of November
9th of November this year uh where those
rules weren't followed the vast majority
of them as you can see 11 of them were
for low relatively low value contracts
below that £100,000 threshold so it's
not as if we've um deviated from rules
that are set in statute however you can
see in the same table there were a
number of instances seven times where we
were presented a case where um officers
wished to deviate from the rules but as
a uh within the procurement of Finance
function and myself as a section 151
officer I wasn't satisfied that they
were um uh in compliance with the
reasons why we would usually allow those
um contracts to be um varied the route
to contract to be varied from our
standard form so you can see it says
that number of reject number of rejected
waivers from July to November there were
7 they set out as along with the waivers
and the reasons for the waivers they're
set out in Annex 4 to this report within
which uh if you go right to the end
you'll see a number of rejected waivers
these were primarily related to um uh
consultancy uh civils and structural uh
Consulting advice that were we were
requiring in relation to to to procure
in relation to the leveling up fund down
at um the the Ramsgate site um there'
been a number of attempts to procure
those contracts or that contract in a
compliant manner however we weren't able
to get any successful biders um we
didn't feel as a finance function and as
officers that uh we could justify uh
signing of the waivers because we
thought they could have continued um to
go back out to the market again however
to do so would have put strain on the on
the project delivery further Downstream
so it was a aged that although they were
deemed non-compliant with our
procurement RS it was still the best
course of action for us to proceed with
such non um compliant peur activity
because that allowed us to deliver the
projects in a timely fashion um in a
similar vein um if you scoot up uh just
a little bit further up on the fourth
page of that Annex there was another
rejected waiver this one in relation to
a marine toilet pod um there had been
some Market engagement between April and
uh July to establish whether you know
the preferred suppliers that they wanted
to use they'd run out of time in order
to um undertake a compliant uh route to
Market our view was within um
procurement function and myself as
section 151 officer that it was an
urgency because of unseen unforeseen
foot uh circumstances it became urgent
because they'd spent too much time at
the pre-market engagement um route it
wasn't unforeseen so that therefore um
it wasn't the waiver was not approved
however it was considered still
appropriate to go forward because the
toilets needed to be purchased in time
if we' said no you can't do that you
need to take a compliant route with our
rules um that they would have
effectively not been able to get the
toilets in place in in time for the
summer season so those I would say the
the high-profile things within this
report that are worth bringing to your
attention you can see that just a
handful across the the long list of
other waivers and the reasons for them
that been put forward but I thought it
was proper and appropriate for me to
bring those ones to your attention happy
to take any questions thank you Chris do
any members have any questions yes
councelor
Davis um I think uh as as well as a
question I'd like to thank you Chris for
the for again a thorough update because
part of a question that had Arisen over
this side was um uh was exactly about
those Council
Acquisitions to do with the leveling up
um I'm not going to try and get into
long discussions about whether the
status of those projects at this point
but I do think that you know it's in and
thank you for your diligence on that
because uh there's there's rather a few
blind alleys available um what I would
like just to bring our attention to um
and again thank you for your um
reporting and transparency is the item
uh to uh Ramsgate Harbor conservation
management plan to support leveling up
funded projects it's an additional
payment of 15,000 to The
Architects um whereby it's lately been
confirmed that a conservation management
plan is required I can assure the the
this chamber that there are many in that
Community including Community groups and
so on that have been yelling this for a
long time and it's the same old excuse
or we didn't know and I'm no disrespect
to anybody in this room but somebody in
these departments is blatantly ignoring
what is obvious there's recently been an
overspend of more than a million on
births four and five and that's a lot of
that's been put down to delays by
getting the environmental impact
assessment uh we now have evidence of
the Harbor Master in 2016 discussing the
need for it so there is there's a weak
Link in this chain somewhere and it
keeps coming back and you know I think
we need a more robust form of
diligence to that end um and I don't
again I'm not trying to Ambush a point
and my colleagues and I have got some
points to make on on on a on a further
item however I believe that there is a
very real risk of this Authority
pedaling backwards to a situation we
were in several years ago whereby
members were not involved sufficiently
in the decision or the scrutiny process
and I think that something that we need
to know but I but I don't want to steal
my colleague Thunder on issues they wish
to raise but again thank you Chris
because if we didn't have such accurate
reporting we wouldn't be able to find
the questions
so thank you uh councelor Davis do you
want to respond to the first point Chris
yeah thank you uh Council Davis um not
sure if there was a question in there
but I I'll try and um talk to the point
try and give you some Assurance around
that um within the procurement function
and the finance service when we are
presented with issues like this um there
is challenge there to understand whether
such instances should have been foreseen
or not as you can see by the fact that
waivers have been rejected when we don't
think things were urgently sometimes
they've just not been planned in the way
that we would like them to do and by
highlighting this well I'm hoping this
transparency improves performance and
future um contract management said to
say or procurement management because
ultimately what we want to achieve
through our purchasing activity is
wherever appropriate to to expose these
comp U contracts to competition because
through going through a competitive
process where we're going out um to buy
Supply services or goods and works you
can demonstrate you've got the best
price for spending Council taxpayers
money if we have to deviate from that it
should be only you know exceptional
circumstances I think another objection
objective not objection objective for us
should be going forward what I'd like to
see is this report to be smaller to
waivers to become more of the exception
rather than the the rules that's another
thing I would be saying for members to
be looking at and challenging is
actually the number have they gone up or
gone down because waivers really should
be an exceptional tool that we use
rather than business as usual in terms
of members involvement and making sure
we're not pedling back from that and
make sure members are involved in the
decision- making process we have uh
you'll see most of these items are of
relatively low value I believe it went
to uh can't remember if it was cabinet
or Council wasn't that long ago the key
decision threshold it might be coming to
Council in a few weeks in terms of the
limits that we have where any spending
decision that is over a quarter of a
million pound so £250,000 has to be
approved by cabinet no officer can
approve spending over that level so in
terms of making sure that members are
involved
key decisions strategic decisions
because that's what the role of members
is in terms of the running the
organization and not getting so too um
bogged down in operational detail but
making sure the organization's going in
the right direction and actually
allocating those resources where uh
they're supposed to be those thresholds
are in place anything over £100,000 as
well something we've been discussed in
our corporate management team we're
going to try improve the transparency so
any expenditure over £100,000 that will
be issuing um officer decision notices
so that they're actually there as a
record that an officer's taken a
decision to to to identify that we've
spent money in that magnitude so
hopefully that gives you a little bit of
assurance in terms of the direction
we're trying to take the authority in
improving the transparency of our
financial reporting and and and and
thank you again for that um one thing
that I'd like to clarify if I could
please um when you're talking about the
thresholds for key decisions and so on
my understanding is that's a cumulative
spend as well on on a project so for
argument sake if a project were a bundle
of smaller spends amounting to a million
it's the spend over the life of the
project that dictates it as a key
decision is that correct what we're
really Keen to do is avoid
disaggregation and um actually this is
one of the reasons why that waiver was
rejected because if you bundled them all
up together they would be above that
threshold where we say statute is in
place and we didn't like the idea of
disaggregating things to a lower level
to Sid step rule so when we're looking
it's it's sometimes it's a bit
subjective but when we're looking at
those instances what we're always trying
to make sure is that things aren't being
disaggregated and looking at things in
isolation when really they're part of a
larger project and it should be you know
those decisions should be looked at um
in terms discreet individual decision
making rather than aggregating things up
so they're not getting the right level
of
scrutiny thanks for that Chris CU it it
does lead to a point that'll be coming
up and it's about the distribution of
government money under the the 1.15
million because that is being moted to
be done and the lottery money but we'll
come to it when it comes to the item but
it's being moted by officers with
absolutely no member input no member
scrutiny or any knowledge of this and
they are engaged with the public and
making and basically offering coffee
that they can't deliver uh or should not
be able to and I'd like it recorded on
every item that the that this level of
scrutiny must be applied we must have a
member-led council not officer- Le
decisions and there's a danger of that
and as I say no disrespect to yourselves
but it's it's an issue and as I say some
evidence will be forthcoming thanks
thank you councelor Davis I do I do want
to sort of address that point because
you've used that word scrutiny a number
of times and one of the things I want to
make sure that governance audit does not
become is a second scrutiny function we
have a scrutiny committee our function
as governance and audit is to look at
the processes of the council make sure
that the process is being followed and
that we have Assurance around things
like the riffs register I will say just
as a councelor elected in may like
yourself coming in um and having
previously served on KCC and been on on
thanet District Council I have found
returning that scrutiny and um the
governance audit process are very
heightened significantly from what I've
seen in the past I think a lot of hard
work is being done by officers and I'll
give you one example um we've had a
number of reports uh in the last year
come to GNA with areas of limited or no
Assurance through Audits and I think a
lot of hard work has been done by
officers to identify that um where this
committee sort of flagged up concerns
back in September that was picked up by
cabinet that was addressed by Chris at
cabinet um and greater focus is being
given to those areas because because one
of one of the challenges we have as a
GNA committee coming in at the moment is
pretty much the entire membership minus
a couple of counselors is brand new and
some of the issues we're dealing with
are very serious I mean we have an
agenda item later um covering some of
these aspects and um it's almost like we
are starting to address some large
issues from the past that we are barely
grappling and understanding at this
stage so we are going on a journey I
would I would hope that members if you
do have concerns about areas can bring
them to this committee and we can talk
about them that that one thing I really
want to be clear about though is we're
not scrutiny there is there is a very
active scrutiny at the moment that is
has the opportunity to call in a lot of
decisions and we just need to get that
back balance right between the two but I
just wanted to address that comment um
do you want to say something Chris yeah
I just would uh probably Echo the points
you've made there chair and I think it's
um it's important perhaps rather than
getting uh too focused on the detail of
particular individual wers but to really
about try to pick out themes as I said
are the numbers going up you know are
are we now seeing waivers for high value
um contracts those are the types of
things those themes that as members
should be trying to identify and ask
questions there but obviously our
offices and I'm very keen to be as
transparent as something the council um
set out in terms of its corporate plan
is for us to improve the transparency in
our reporting that's something that as
officers we we want to try and bring
that to the council to allow councilors
to ask those questions as well chair can
I just come in as well um just really to
support everything that Chris has said
and obviously there is predis I mean I'm
not trying to confuse this with um this
committee with scrutiny but obviously
there is predecision scrutiny that has
been introduced um and also just to say
to reiterate just the commitment
absolute commitment to transparency one
of the things that um we have been
discussing is looking at the um you know
decision-making processes we're looking
at the member officer protocol and all
of that hopefully will eyon out some of
the issues that you've raised and you've
been concerned about going
forward thank you thank you very much
ingred that was very com definitely
remiss of me not to um welcome ingred to
her first GNA meeting so opportunity
welcome um Council to did you want to
come in
sorry um leing on from counc Davis and
listening to what you said Chris is the
the breakdown of of actually amounts
that you talk about a quarter of million
pounds is a is a threshold that you have
to then thereafter refer to the to the
to the to the to the election members
cabinet what is it that that could stop
that happening is that you have a
contract it's worth a million quid and
the officers break it down to be in in a
way that they don't need to bring that
forward and keep it below quarter of a
million quid what are the safeg guards
to ensure that that doesn't
happen um it's a good question I would
say we're relyant on um the good
officers within the legal services that
would who so the contracts need of a
certain value think it's over over 100
,000 is reviewed by Legal Services it
will be going through my procurement
team as well with a with a Matt service
so those are the types of thing when
we're looking at signing a contract to
make sure things aren't disaggregated to
avoid or evade that level of
transparency um so uh I think as well in
terms of within the system orders so
sorry within our financial system orders
of a value over £100,000 have to be
signed off by a director or head of
service so you you can't have officers
at junior level um approving orders of a
higher value so there's there's a there
I'm trying to think any other controls I
mean we're largely Reliant I would say
on the scrutiny of those within the
procurement function and um legal
function but something else you want to
add Matt sorry to put you on the
spot only that from a monitoring
perspective as well in order it before
they can even go to contracts they we we
as a finance team individually have to
sign off on the fact that the budget's
available so if I'm looking at a budget
in the system for a contract where I
know that the annual value of the
contract is 250,000 I'd be challenging
why all of a sudden the contract that
was a four-year contract is going
through as a single year so that
disaggregation opportunity would have be
limit eliminated at that point in time
so you can't progress to the points that
Chris has just raised without the sign
off on the budget in the first instance
so there's already a pre preliminary
check before it's even got to that
point
any other
questions councelor bright I apologize
it's okay um so as councilor scobby said
most of us are on you um and I'm looking
at this and and we said is it getting
better over time now obviously if I'm
looking at this in in in the in the view
that you've given us going from 2021
onwards we're obviously making really
good progress here but I'm my question
is really how much you know 2021
2122 was was were very odd years right
so I'm I'm assuming that TDC were making
an awful lot of decisions that they had
to make very quickly um they didn't have
time to scrutinize them properly because
the council was kind of almost barely
functioning um due not just to
governance issues but due to due to
covid um what would it look like if we
went back even further I mean what does
good look like cuz obviously we' we've
come down by over over 100% year on
year but would that stand scrutiny if we
compared it to say 2016
2017 Chris excellent question and I
don't have the answer to that um yeah
you're you're right obviously uh
pandemic was a peculiar time for us all
and public sector procurement was no no
different to that um there was some um
we did make some changes to our local
rules at that time so as as it says in
report um have to get three quotes for
anything over £10,000 during the
pandemic we increased that to
25,000 um just because we needed to move
at such Pace you know to to procure
things um you know getting things done
quickly was of more important than
demonstrating you've necessarily got the
absolute best possible price during that
time um can look to actually um to to
try and get some further um data going
back into those years to to demonstrate
the trends over that time uh I think the
only the only the only again difference
in caveat I'll probably put on that and
while we obviously want to see the
numbers going down the spend profile of
the authority is also changed recently
most as talking about leveling up funds
and the Margate Town deal on the size of
the capital program we're spending more
money and in gauging in with more
contracts so that obviously presents
more opportunities for waivers as well
so um we'll we'll do we'll do some work
and try to make sure we've got some
meaningful comparators for you over a
lengthier period of time I I think it
would be a good idea but obviously I do
accept the fact that this is about
improving going on rather than just
looking back but it would be good just
to have an
idea thank you very much members I think
that was quite an interesting discussion
um we are the recommendation is that we
note this report can I have a proposal
in a second for noting please councilor
briter proposing can have a second up
councilor bright seconding a members
agreed
we have noted it okay agenda item seven
we have Auditor's annual report I have
Chris down to speak but I'm assuming
this will be Nick halwell or somebody
from Grant
thoron yes very much so um I will be
passing over to my colleagues but just
just by very short brief um form of
introduction to report so um Sarah Monga
uh Nick and uh Matt with us from Grant
thoron tonight who will present their
actual annual audit report but the
you'll see in front of that's a covering
report that hopefully sets out um a
little bit of context in terms of our uh
position uh as officers how we view this
um quite rightly it's been well you know
it's been uh well said before so I won't
go into the ins and outs of all it was a
very challenging period of time for the
authority that this uh review covers in
terms of the work that they've done for
us on our position on Valley for money
um I think if you when you look at some
of the report and the the traffic like
rag rating system it can look still
quite alarming if you look at it it just
on um surface level but I think once you
scratch below that and the the ne you
know the detail within uh Sarah's report
you can see actually that progress has
been made you know in most notably since
20 22 23 very different to uh the
environment we're operating in 2021 and
2122 the report the covering report that
um myself and colleagues have uh
produced does set out some of the you
know the progress that we've made since
then in terms of you know really pleased
to be say that we've got ingred with us
now who was the final member of our
corporate management team to be
appointed so we've got a full compliment
of um uh officers at that senior level
now there are rightly still some things
we need to improve on and and still need
to work and we are working on those um
it's been spoken about four improving
the the way that we communicate with
members in terms of the provision of
information that we're getting to you uh
I know I know that's really important to
members to councilors and it's important
to us too and we're working really hard
to try and get that that right as ingred
referred to earlier in terms of the
officer member protocol that be coming
to council soon that we'll be setting
out um in some more detail um the types
of information how it will be provided
what members are entitled to be asking
for all those times of things that we
know we need to improve on project
management procurement we've um
commissioned um an an external
consultant who'll be joining us next
week actually um to begin the review
with that that complements the work
that's already been done by Christine
Parker and and her team and in terms of
the recommendations that she made on
review of the B four five project and
project management in general we've also
set up a governance working group that
will be meeting soon and alongside the
property working group so of those three
working groups two of them actually met
today uh first meeting for the project
management uh working group property
working groups in meeting for a while
already in the Govern working group has
got its first meeting coming up um very
shortly so that's all I've got to say so
at this point I'll hand over to sah I'm
sure we'll um go through her report in
detail thank you it's um it's nice to be
back in your chamber although I
appreciate many of you will not have met
me before I'm Sarah ironmonger I am the
engagement partner who signed your 1920
and 2021 accounts on my far right is
Matt Dean who was your engagement lead
for 2122 and 2223 and in between us is
the senior manager with that consistency
who's the person who is here on the
ground so that's that's why you see all
three of us to here tonight um we're
presenting this interim annual Auditors
report the reason it is interim um is
there variety of different reasons for
each of the three years but what we were
really keen on was to kind of get you
into that catchup place where we've
we've caught up the three years so that
you can be focusing on what you're doing
now uh in response to this so interim
for 2021 because we've got some
objections members may be aware that
local government electors can make
formal objections to the accounts we are
we are coming in to to land on the last
few of those so we're hope that we'll be
able to close those soon um and as you
know uh 2122 audit is just beginning so
this has to remain interim until those
things have come to a conclusion in case
that work draws out anything else we
want to report to you so we will then
update it if there is anything we need
to report to you so that's what that's
what this is um if I turn you to page 69
as as Chris points out it it does look a
little alarming with those red red rag
ratings um although many of you weren't
here 2021 is represented a change of
code so the National Audit office sets
the code the Auditors follow uh that
changed in
2021 um and we report against three
criteria governance improving economy
efficiency and Effectiveness and
financial sustainability and we're
required to give you a commentary on our
view of those arrangements so that's
that's what this is you can clearly see
there are
issues um and and what I think I'd
really encourage members is is actually
to understand after this meeting how are
you implementing the progress that you
need to be making you know you want to
be seeing that Improvement as you get in
as the council stabilizes and and builds
on from where you've been so as you get
into 23 24 actually are you seeing that
that Improvement in some of these areas
so that's that's what I would sort of
counsel you to be paying uh paying
attention to going forward what I plan
to do was to just go through the
executive summary it's a very lengthy
report happy to take questions on any of
it but I thought I'd just take you
through the exec summary because that's
just the kind of the headlines really so
on page
79 um we move into governance is our
First theme and within that you've got
the council wide governance and
transparency so um I did sit in this
chamber and present the statutary
recommendations back in October 21 I
think those have been well publicized
about the challenges that you've had now
what that does lead us to is there were
clearly issues and we're saying there
was a significant weakness in your
Arrangements around governance for each
of the three years now you have made
progress you did an action plan uh in
response to to our recommendations and
in response to the independent
monitoring officer um and you have made
really good progress on those but by the
end of 22 23 not everything was fully
implemented so we're saying the
significant weakness remains for each of
those years um we can see things are
improving we just want to see that
they're embedded before we lift that and
absolutely that'll be something we look
at in 2324 so that's that first
area beneath that kind of council-wide
governance is the service level
governance um and of course rightly
there was focus on the go on on the
whole governance of the council but
actually if you look at what was going
on um internal audit have uh been
publishing an increasing number of
limited and no Assurance internal audit
reports and actually if we start to pull
out some of the themes within that
there's a real uh common cause of either
a lack of underlying policies and
procedures or compliance with those so
what we're saying is actually this is
really showing a weakness in your
arrangements and your services um and
you want to be seeing um it's it's a one
level it's great you're getting that
Assurance it tells you but you want to
be seeing that Improvement and
addressing those going forward so we are
saying that there is a significant
weakness in that service um service
governance um and then the final area
within governance we've picked up is
risk management our recommendations uh
within risk management and reference to
internal La it's all about Improvement
recommendations so in terms of
technicality where we say this is
significant weakness we have a key
recommendation and that's something we
really want you to be paying attention
to um where we see something to improve
we will we will report that to you but
that's more about improving the
arrangements we're not saying that it's
um it's moving you more towards good
practice and best practice rather than
saying there a significant weakness so
it's just just understanding the
distinction between those type of
recommendations um so there's just a
little bit we think you can do to
improve improve risk management um
internal audit that we're really pleased
to see over the time period um that
actually relationships are really
working and uh really improving and
we're seeing much better response to
what internal audit is saying to you um
and and there's just a little thing of
which I think internal audit already had
in place to get the internal to get that
external peer review because that's good
practice so that's what we were that's
our headlines on governance looking at
improving efficiency economy efficiency
Effectiveness in
2021 um the cabinet did not receive any
reports in relation to the non-financial
performance of the council and we
therefore consider that a significant
weakness you should have been informed
um I know many in this chamber were not
were not members at that time but that's
our view we can see improvements have
been made we can see actually there have
been greater improvements in 22 23 at
member requests um to have greater
Clarity so it's just an area that we
think you it's a really important point
it's important to your residents it's
just something that you need to
understand the performance of of those
services so that's that area project and
contract management has come up in the
discussion around waivers um clearly we
think that's a really important area um
in this we did we were aware of the
birth 45 the independent monitoring
officer spoke about it internal audit
has done has done a review and you know
we've looked at that and we do think
there were weaknesses in project
management arrangements and therefore
we're calling that a significant
weakness again with a key
recommendation um there are on the next
page a couple of other elements of this
where um there's an objection that we
just need to work through to see if
there's anything else that comes out of
it and we're aware of more allegations
that are being made so we would just we
would just recommend that that's just
something you just keep on your keep
keep paying attention to you know when
there's anything to report um and have
every confidence internal audit will
tell you if when there is something to
say if there is something to say but
just keep that on just keep that as an
area because it is really important that
you get your project and um contract
management
right turning to the third theme which
is financial
sustainability um clearly and we've
referenced it today um Financial
sustainability for in local government
is a real challenge it's a challenge for
many many
authorities um what um there were a
number of issues with the 2021 um
because of everything else that was
going on so those accounts have now been
signed um but actually there were no
outturn reports coming to you as members
for 2122 or 22 23 and and the accounts
have been delayed now that that is not a
position that any of us should be
comfortable in um and it's a you whil we
completely understand the hard work
officers have been doing if an issue
emerged it's very hard for members to
ask the right questions at the right
time um I know how hard the finance team
have been working and responding to us
and and all the different calls on their
time because of what's been going on for
the council um but I think we're just
saying to you this really does need to
be um accelerated and picked up I'm
pleased to say since we wrote this
report you have published your 2122
accounts um and we've got a timetable
for when 2223 has happened um at this
stage we haven't identified anything
that would have been very alarming that
you should have heard about earlier um
but you know we are just at the early
stages of that audit so I just think
that's just something that um you know
it we understand how it's happened but
we do think should be should be better
going forward um and then of course that
links into uh that final page around
reserves and savings there are you know
you have you have managed your deficits
in the past you have managed to increase
your reserves they have been
historically low for for comparative
counselors counsels um but there is you
have got pressures when you look forward
um and 5.8 million may not sound a large
figure when you compare to some of the
other local authorities but it's quite
large for you um and and your options
you the sooner you can tackle what
savings plans transformation you're
going to do the sooner you can Implement
them which can help m at the size of
those savings that you need to do so um
you that's something that we're
expecting to expecting to see you build
on um and then the final point is around
budget setting um and and how that's
working um and really some improvements
on that and the very very final point is
on your Capital project I think you know
you're very you're aware that you've
been very successful in uh being awarded
funding for the town deal the leveling
up funds they are large amounts of money
they are rely on your governance
arrangements and your project and
contract management now given that we
have already criticized your governance
arrangements and we have criticized your
project management Arrangements these
are areas you you have you've managed to
secure this funding for your residents
you need to make best use of that
funding so what we are saying to you is
you know you need to tackle these other
other issues so that you are making the
best use of this and um and and so
really that's just that's kind of our
Whistle Stop tour through a three-year
there's a there's a lot there's a lot to
look forward to that you understand your
issues you've got these issues here but
you do need to be making that progress
I'm really happy to pause there and take
any
questions thank you very much um Sarah
and Chris for the introduction um I just
want to make um some comments myself as
chair I think um your report's quite
difficult reading I think it's um some
of the issues raised and the challenges
to the council running over that period
are quite hard um I take some comfort
from the fact that quite a bit of this
is a lagging
indicator and um I guess it's quite
difficult as quite a new committee and
quite a new management team of the
council to um deal with some of this
because we didn't start the fire and it
sort of afterwards trying to deal with
some of the issues um I I would say that
um we are on a path where improvements
are being seen but I completely accept
the comments that you've made and the
report and I think it's a a really good
Line in the Sand Point to reflect upon
and say we we've made some progress but
there's still a lot more to do so I
thank you very much for your report very
very robust um members does anybody have
any comments councelor Garner to
start thank you thank you Sarah for I
Echo what councelor scobby says it is a
difficult difficult report um and
there's a lot in there I mean I'm one of
the few who was here previously so I've
I've I've bear witness to some of the
difficulties that we've been through uh
previously um I've got a couple of
things I just wanted to mention and ask
about really the first is around that
that first page page 69
and the three areas that remain red and
have been red in fact there were three
red there were just two a couple of
years ago now I know we're all aware
that there's a lot of work going on a
lot of people lot of officers are
working very hard councilors are working
very hard to improve this but we need to
I I think I need to and we need to
understand when we should expect to see
these things changing when the red
turning from red to Amber to Green so
that we can understand when we should be
concerned that it isn't turning that way
I mean I
assume one of my expectation I think our
expectations would be when we come when
we're sitting here this time next year
for the next annual report none of these
will be read and if any of them are read
then we don't want to get here next year
and see and red we want to be in we want
to be aware of that so as we can try and
do something about it and so you know
I've heard a lot of nice words about
yeah we are working hard we are doing a
lot but we really need to see some
evidence of of that happening and maybe
if you could comment on
that but if I can drill down to one area
that I am it sort of links into that one
area that I am and I know a number of
are really concerned about is that area
around project and contract management I
mean we all we all know we' we've all
read what happened with birth 4 and five
we all know that there was a very
significant overspend there and I think
we we accept that the one of the main
reasons for that was because of our lack
of project management
experience and not having the processes
in place
um as you say we've got a much bigger
budget now with the leveling up and town
deal
fund um I know we're sort of pinning our
hopes on the fact that we've applied to
be part of the pilot scheme and we're
hoping that that pilot scheme being a
member of that pilot scheme that will
bring some of the project and contract
management uh skills or knowledge that
we don't necessarily have but that can
only be for the council can I think it
can only be a temporary sort of
mitigation it doesn't that doesn't
negate the need for us to really tackle
that lack of project management and
contract management expertise experience
process and procedures and whether or
not we we are part of that pilot scheme
in parallel we need to be I think will
agree we need to be tackling that issue
um so that when we we come to our own
projects we don't have any any issues or
or if we do get any overspends we know
why early on because we've got the
rigorous processes and procedures in
place um so there there were two things
here and in fact that makes me think of
a third one in a way because he
mentioned we are receiving from um
internal audits reports a lot of limited
or no assurance and that's that's been
happening for quite a long time and a
lot of that is as you said because of a
lack of processes and procedures in
place but one yes it's good that we're
identifying that and we can do something
about it but we we really need to start
seeing things being done about it you
know we there's a lot there to be done
so we we need to see that plan happening
so I think that that covers what I
wanted to say thank you yeah
yeah absolutely you know your your
points are very valid uh you are you are
on a on a journey and it is it is very
challenging when you've had the
experience that you've had as a council
um I think there are a number of
elements you know you do now have uh a
senior management team that that are now
in post so you get that you get that
stability there that can drive in some
of that change particularly around
getting policies and procedures there
are other local authorities that you can
learn from and getting that um that
culture of compliance where people are
actually doing doing things in line with
those policies and procedures that you
have you have agreed so that that's
that's a very very good starting point
and somewh that needs to happen you know
you will want to be sitting here in a
year's time seeing improvements from
what we've got to say but actually there
will be things that you should be seeing
coming through through before then um so
you it's great that internal audit will
look at very specific services and tell
you what they're seeing because that's
step one if you know what's happening
you've got a chance to do it actually um
if you you'll be getting updates during
the year and you would want to see you
would want to see where previous issues
have been identified and reported that
those recommendations are being
implemented and that you are seeing
progress so that may well show you your
direction of travel as you progress
during the year um it may be that you
want to talk to officers and ask for um
update what I've seen other councils
where we've had some very difficult me
messages actually they said after 6
months can we have an update from
officers on where you think we are
against our
recommendations um I think there's
something around this this group within
the audit committee um asking those
questions when you see something going
hang on a sec is this is this making us
move forward so that you you keep that
Focus so if you've got external audit
internal audit officers and members all
focused on that Improvement you it gives
you your best chance of this looking
significantly better next year you know
there's always the opportunity that some
specific project has gone wrong and
there will be there'll be something
reported but I think you know if we look
at that Financial sustainability you
know I know the conversations I'm having
with Chris you know around catching that
up and getting that in a better position
um that should look better from from
everything we understand you know but
actually if you're not getting outturn
reports you know asking those questions
if you're not you know if the um you
understanding why you're not getting
pieces of information yeah is important
because of the difficulties yeah and and
and I can't quite emphasize much just
how much the fin team that we'd normally
deal with have not been able to focus on
maybe what we might normally see because
they're dealing with all these other
pieces you know if you can stabilize
that they can go back to focusing on
what they normally do you start to make
that progress um you know so that that
is a really important piece within this
I think you that project
management with the size of funding
you've got yes take the help you can
from a pilot scheme but actually you
need to be thinking about what skills do
you need within the council to deliver
that and that may be something that you
want to be asking questions on and and
and and seeking assurances you know but
but almost don't just wait for the
external auditor to tell you in 12
months time you have other sources of
assurance that you can you can
gain thank you very much I have uh
councelor BR coming in then councel
towning thank you for your report and
welcome back
um so reporting is is a bit of a bug
bear for me um I would and and and I
note with interest that you you identify
it as a bit of a weakness particularly
we have these huge projects that that we
need to manage
now the issue that I have is is I've
asked for reports and I'm part of the AV
and scrutiny committee and we've asked
for reports um and are variously being
told that either the projects are too
complex to give you simple enough
reports or we don't have the oppos
officer time to give you in-depth
reports now what does good look like for
a project do you as as an external
auditor do you have a view on what a
good report on a on a project that could
keep us updated might look like because
I'm really concerned that there are
these big projects and we are not given
I don't want basically I don't want to
get to a stage where these projects are
in danger of being delivered and we
haven't been able to scrutinize it or to
audit it properly
I mean there's plenty of examples of uh
good practice in project management
reporting and certainly we can talk to
we can we can um Chris and I can talk
about some of those examples the theme
that I would draw out though is you want
to know are we on track with what we're
trying to achieve and if you're going
off track you want to know that early so
that you can make decisions about what
to do about that now projects go off
track for a number of reasons but you
want to know and understand what those
reasons are and would you make a
different decision yeah and that's that
that is the point of project management
and the point of understanding it um you
know there are there are authorities who
are able to able to do this um it is
time consuming you know capital projects
of this size often sit at much larger
authorities who have a much larger
officer team and um and some of this is
your risk rewards sort of balance
between how much you want to spend on
some of those those that buying that
skill in uh whether it's consultancy or
your own people um and how much you've
got to manage some of your other
services and you do have to wrestle with
some of those
conversations I think you know what I
would encourage you is if you're not
getting the answers you want really
engaged with the officers um to come up
with to come up with the plan
because the current the current senior
officers that we're dealing with have
been very responsive to us we've been
we've had good answers and we can have a
debate with them um and that's that's
important about how we move
forward BR you just want to come back
that I'm going be CHR yeah I I would
just like to add the other point that I
would kind of like to remind officers
particularly is that we're quite a good
resource in terms of just you know
things will go wrong I think we all know
that things will go wrong on these the
these enormous projects a lot of the
challenges that you we're going to be
faced as a council are external there's
inflationary pressures on building
materials Etc and quite often you get a
lot of voices out in the community
criticizing the work that the council
are doing and quite frankly a lot of the
councilors and the members of all
stripes are the First on platforms
defending officers defending the work
that the council is doing so the more
information that we have to say look yes
it went wrong but here's why or yes it
went wrong but don't worry this is being
done instead the more information we've
got the more transparency we've got the
better job we can do making sure that
we're standing by the officers
throughout the the organization and
making sure that they're defended where
they need to be thank you Chris you want
to come in chair um yeah couple of
things there on the reporting of project
management um the lots of these projects
are large Capital schemes and and um I
know there clearly been reported there
was some weakness in our budget
monitoring and outter reporting which is
largely been addressed now um the report
that Matt and his team produced we'
we've been making sure that the
information there on the individual
schemes whether it's Margate Town deal
or leveling up projects it's at a more
granular level so it's not just how
saying leveling up um x million pound
we've got a break down below that where
we are with a lot of those schemes if
they not actually got into actual
delivery um phase yet in terms of the
planning they're still at an early stage
um of delivery which probably why you're
not seeing that information coming
through
um however that you know we've got
structures in place within our um at an
officer level now to manage those uh
those projects at uh a corporate level
um so there's High you know High
importance strategic projects they'll be
going through the project board that was
referred to in the um covering reports
and we've got the um as I was saying
earlier the projects uh reporting me in
the uh budget monitoring report that go
to Cabinet on a quarterly basis um just
again just I suppose in form of Defense
just looking at the uh recommendation so
Council Garner's question about when it
will get better I think in terms of uh
recommendation five around the outturn
and budget monitoring that's that has
already improved uh um
2122 was an unusual uh Time For Us in
terms of where we were at the outter
point then um when we typically would
have been producing that report the
chief executive left the organization um
as did pretty much the rest of the top
management tier Matt and I were spread
very thin in terms of our ability to
produce those reports the final accounts
themselves were outstanding as well
which meant that we were in a position
to say what the final position was I
think in a perfect world if we'd had the
resource we still would have brought a
draft outter report by the time the
accounts were um closer to completed
than the 2122 was still being audited
now the the time had passed so when
you're looking at financial reporting
timeliness is as important as your
accuracy so there was seemed to be
little value in bringing the
2122 budget um uh out to report them
because the accounts are still being
audited um we'd already got into 2223
budget monitoring we'd set the 2324
budget the ship had kind of sailed at
that point 2223 out report on police say
has already been reported so that's gone
to cabinet so I can't I would consider
those two out reports discharged and
Matt and I we're working with a team to
make sure that the recommendation in
there is limited to a TW month time lag
that's not as easy as it sounds um that
is in some instances particular when
you've got a Christmas break in in the
middle of it if you're reporting at the
end of December to get a report pulled
together at the end of February with the
committee timetable it is quite
challenging we're working um in order to
do that and then just finally just um on
the performance
reporting um acknowledge the weakness
there in 2021 but it was a really weird
year it was it was in the middle of the
pandemic and some things we just had to
stop doing there was limited officer
capacity to get in order to make sure we
were still fun
and unfortunately Performance Management
was one of them that fell by the wayside
um but we recognize that's not something
we would ever want to be doing under
business as usual and we have addressed
that and made Improvement
subsequently thank you Chris um I have
councelor towning councelor Davis and
councelor maners down to speak so I'll
come to you first councelor towning
councel right councel right thank you
well how nice to see you
again um I want to go back to my
questions that I have raised in the past
with you and I'm sure you are familiar
with where I'm going
now the 18 2018
2021 period when I raised on a number of
occasions the non-disclosure payments
that were made unfortunately I was put
to one side purely because there was a
different uh investigation taking place
and we couldn't really go down that road
well I do believe that we are
responsible for the management of the
public funds of this uh institution of
ours but no one has ever I'm not
interested in who got paid who never got
paid I'm interested in how much was
paid but no one has ever told us that
and I do believe that we are entitled to
know that and we should be
told the other point I'd like to make S
is that your great report I I think it
covers a lot of areas
and I think it was a difficult one to
write because there so much has
happened uh the council has changed
remarkably with a
new1 officer you know
who who does a great job
um um you talk about
improvements and there have been
improvements but what you don't talk
about is improvements that haven't
happened and what those improvements
are so when would we find out what
improvements you're looking for to to
improve
further because we don't know what you
you know what the what is outstanding in
your thinking of the of the workings of
the
council thank
you um on the ndas uh I think there's
two elements of that one is we have uh
an objection uh related to nondisclosure
of agreements um that we are drawing to
a close on um so we will respond to that
elector um in terms of the amounts paid
those will have been in the accounts
they are they are disclosed in a in a
note to the accounts and and I'm sure
the finance team can show you exactly
which ones in each in each year so they
they are disclosed they may not any exit
path cage will be disclosed in the
accounts so that information is there
uh further to that as well um so for any
senior officer if there was a
termination agreement or an exit package
that would be um specified by the
officer level so if if you're talking
about the previous corporate management
team um when we entered into those
arrangements with them they were um
under sort of closed session because
they were private sort of employment
matters but we're very clear that those
amounts would be disclosed within our
accounts I think um one of the certainly
has been published the other one will be
in 22 23 certain the high value ones
that were um in there so there is that
um transparency it's a requirement for
us to do it any other value um related
to an exit package that is not relating
to a senior officer will be in there but
it's an abandoned table so you'll be
able to see the number of exit packages
that we've agreed to or I think it's
difficult not to confuse perhaps the
difference or conflate um non-disclosure
agreements with exit packages sometimes
an exit package can happen for other
reasons sometimes an exit package may
include what you might refer to as a you
know non-disclosure agreement um we
don't break that down the accounts but
what we will give you is a list of um uh
if I'm right it'll be redundancies and
then other exit agreements and you can
see that in a table of um table format
within the accounts I'm happy to show
you where they are they'll be on our
website up to 212 2 yeah so just just
for clarity then so that information
some of that is available now and some
of that is coming soon in in accounts
correct so the 22 23 so I mean to um
perhaps address just address the
elephant in the room if you're looking
at the exit of the previous deputy chief
executive that is published in the 2122
if you're looking for the previous uh
chief executive that will be in our soon
to be published draft 2223 accounts and
that's all just on the public record um
it's suppose again um as Sarah said this
has been considered as part of um an
objection to the council whether it's
appropriate because exit packages can be
used appropriately as a tool to for you
know for an individual or an officer to
leave the organization without you know
attributing blame to either party for
appropriate reasons they can you know
they can be used appropriately what
you've got to make sure is that they're
not used inappro appropriately and I
think that's the whole point of the
objection to look at have these you know
have these uh exit packages been used in
disproportionate or inappropriate uh
manner just finally last point the other
thing to bear in mind is any exit
package over £100,000 has to be approved
by full Council so again in terms of
talking about the authority that um uh
officers have to enter extra packages
that's capped 100,000 and that includes
the pension strain as well doesn't it so
in terms of the value of someone's
accessing their pension early full
Council would need to consider that and
believe it or not that's actually
sometimes not that relatively senior
officers if you're talking about the
value of someone's um pension plus the
redundancy you can get into what you
would consider perhaps relatively Junior
officers if they've got um long Service
attached to them so sorry that was a
roundabout way saying it's it is out
there but I'm happy to have further
discussions through the Council of town
if if there's anything particularly one
sight of just just specific to that and
I know we've got three speakers but just
specifically to that does the council
have DN Insurance on senior officers and
if there was a payout related to that
how would that be treated in the account
would that be a deduction of the
payments or would that be separately
maybe a bit of a specific issue
so Amy's better to speak to the specific
insurance policies he our insurance that
type of
insurance in terms of the accounting
treatment we show it gross so we would
still show the value of the settlement
and then the income would be separate we
wouldn't net them off in terms of not
dis disclosing but as said I mean I'm
not aware and not me any claims against
that okay interesting apologies to the
other speakers councelor Davis I've got
you
next thank you chair and again thank you
Sarah and colleagues for uh what we know
for some time there been a very robust
and far-reaching Report um and I'm
pleased to see that it's still being
investig iated because some of us do
know what a can of worms birth four and
five actually is uh and continues to be
um what I wanted to ask was what um and
and again it relates to our corporate
priority of transparency the
administration's commitment to it Grant
Thornton's
recommendations we do have uh I'm not
trying to steal a word off my colleague
here we have we seem to have a
culturable cultural issue here um in
that there are certain officers and
departments that will go out of their
way to avoid any member involvement in
setting up the terms of governance an
example on this is what I mentioned
earlier the shared Prosperity fund and
what and and why this is relevant is
because we're going to be asked to
approve this evening a report that says
that the distribution in the future of
the lottery funds will follow the model
that has been established for the shared
Prosperity fund the shared Prosperity
fund is 1.15 million therefore a key
decision has not the process has not
come through overview and scrutiny or
cabinet you've got officers making
decisions as to who will attend meetings
uh how members are expected but those
governance issues sorry Jer if I well no
no just just if I may say we're
obviously going to cover that agenda
item when I would like when we had that
discussion to have had the officers
input before we discuss it because some
members may not be fully aware of what
you're referring to so I understand
you're making a more trying drill to is
there is a cultural issue here and it it
and it has got worse rather than better
despite uh M monger's recommendations
that in order to avoid repetition of
issues the council should seek to
immediately apply the Lessons Learned we
don't have to have working groups
consultations pity parties or anything
else for officers to actually do the job
they are employed to rather than look
like a good advert for the Peter
Principle at times because it's either
incompetent or something else is very
wrong when members are being denied
their their constitutional right to
engage with the
community okay I I think I think your
comments are noted and we will obviously
cover them again the agenda it's fine
you're entitled to to make your comments
but um we'll we'll pick them up again
when we come on to that agenda item
specifics when the officers introduced
that Council of manners I had you down
next uh thank you chair and thank you
Sarah um I was um I was only elected for
the first time in in May so um it it is
when I when I first um stood I was told
by several former members don't even go
there um there were serious um
aspersions cast on the transparency and
efficacity of this
organization um and they said you're
going to be banging your head against
the brick wall so it is encouraging when
I see that there is work being done here
on govern governance um but I there is a
feeling um I I'm sort of coming across a
culture in as uh John has mentioned um
where you do feel that you're kept in
the dark um I mean I see here for
example there seems to be a it seems to
be a cultural issue um I know it's on
your um report here the where are we uh
external Auditor's annual audit report
on value for money that um there's a
property working group being set up I
mean we only find out about these things
postmortem we don't we don't have any
say in in in how they're constituted or
how they they come about um but my
question would be why is there no member
involvement in that process um when you
think about the property assets that
exist in in our respective Wards we know
what the footfall is we know what the
local market conditions might be like we
know what problems uh local Traders
might be facing um we know what
opportunities might exist there perhaps
more so than uh professionals that get
parachuted in with fat consultancy fees
uh but we're not consulted we're almost
we're we're kept in the dark about this
um when we're looking at the uh John's
mentioned about the leveling up fund
which you you've mentioned um1 1.15
million
the commity money that's being allocated
there is really important to the
community it it actually it's a really
efficient way of delivering um benefits
to the community probably a lot more
efficient than many of the the council
services without the apportioned
overhead and so on uh and Community
groups do a really amazing job in in
getting the money where it's most needed
um and yet the all of the decisions on
that appear we're only finding this out
again post morem because there was no
consultation with any elected members uh
that the entirety of the decision-making
process for that is uh down to officers
with no input whatsoever again from
Members um
so as I say I mean it just comes back to
this this feeling that that members are
very often simply kept in the dark uh
and that there are still cultural
changes that that need to be made in in
the governance here thank
you I mean I think we've said before
that you are definitely on a journey um
here the you know I talked about the
council wide governance I referred to
the statutory recommendations that I
made in October 21 and one of those was
about reaching an agreed understanding
about officer and
member relationships interaction um and
that is defin you know it's not easy I
don't think there's any Council that
actually really has got that exactly
right but it was definitely something
that you need to be working on because
statute recommendations that we use that
power that's quite rare to use um you
know there's a lot of councils up and
down the country who've never had that
type of recommendation given to them at
that profile so yeah that expresses the
level of seriousness that we were taking
with it um the independent monitoring
officer came up with some
recommendations there is progress being
made around kind of what what are some
of these behavioral issues what the and
the restructuring of the senior
management team just so that you've got
permanent people that you can be
building those relationships and have
those difficult conversations about and
it is a balance between there's a lot of
operational pieces that members you
members won't have the site on because
it needs to operationally happen it's
just around getting that framework
really clear so you know at you often
talk about governance being almost like
um like on a football pitch you want to
know if it's going outside of the lines
you don't necessarily need to know if
things are just running alongside the
lines that you want them to be so I
think there's a piece around
understanding which projects which
working
groups Merit having member involvement
or at what stage because actually at
some points the officers can do an awful
lot of work and then bring it to you um
with going actually we've looked at
these different options we've because
your time is limited as well you know
you're not you're not full-time members
of Staff um and so I think there is a
process here but you are coming from a
backdrop of that relationship not
working um not going into the reasons
why it didn't work but it wasn't working
in a productive way and it is just an
area that we really think you we've we
we thought was wrong we've said so you
have made progress and I think it's one
that just needs to keep working aware at
I know um the chief exec I know the
senior officers will be very keen to do
that and and it's about having those
conversations a lot of them maybe not in
this chamber it's around those
conversations around how do we do this
let's have an agreed understanding
because I think that's where we come
from you need an agreed understanding
about where you have involvement what
you're informed about what you what
comes back to you um I was just going to
say my my colleague Nick that's why we
bring him reminded me when one of you
asked about uh procurement and contract
management we did actually Grant
Thornton did actually issue um like a
report based on sector research last
month um so I will send that to Chris
and he can he can circulate that to you
I mean it's publicly available but it
just gives some messages of what we've
seen across the
country uh thank you sir U can I just
come back on that briefly and then I'm
going to bring in the monitoring yeah um
I didn't want to paint a a portrait of
it being entirely gloom and doom the the
training uh that we had was really
useful and and as as yeah it it it's
really and and it was sort of it
demonstrates a um a commitment to
changing the culture here I would like
to see more on that and I think that's a
top- down thing that comes from the
chief executive um to to work with the
officers to engage more with members and
I hope that that will happen that there
will be a process where um officers will
be encouraged to engage with with with
members thanks just before moning
officer comes in we def def progressed
in the last 3 years I don't have members
contacting me most weeks with concerns
that is that is a step forward because
that's not the auditor's role to be
managing that whereas I think most of
those conversations are happening with
officers thank you ingred do you want to
come in really just to say obviously
I've just been in post a little over um
a month now and I've got a real sense
that there's a absolute commitment to
changing the culture of the past and
obviously one of the things that I
I was tasked with even before I started
actually was looking at the member
officer protocol and I know I mentioned
that previously but one of the key
features of that is how members and
officers work together obviously but
it's also about the flow of information
between members and officers and I'm
really Keen that we get that right um
and so I've done a I've prepared an
initial draft it's it's at it's for
discussion and obviously members will be
considering that and so I hope going
forward that that that you know that
working relationship and those
boundaries be much clearer and that you
as members with all sorts of other
commitments don't have to get um you
know bogged down in the tiny myi of
operational detail but that you feel
that you're getting enough information
to properly exercise your duties and so
I'm really committed to that and I'm
really committed to making sure that
you're all involved in in in looking at
that and reviewing at that and that and
that we get this right for for for
thanet District Council the other thing
I'd like just to say um is that if
you've got any concerns about
Constitution impropriety in any regard
please do bring them to my attention and
I absolutely undertake to look into
those you know thoroughly and fully
thank you thank you ingr I've got a
counselor right thank you chair um my
colleagues have virtually said
everything but I would like to say
something um not many of you know I was
right in the thick of what happened with
the senior management team so but what I
would like to do I would like it noted
say thank you to Chris CU I don't think
if without Chris blundel I don't think
we would have
been on the on the ship that we're on
now so thank you
Chris thank you uh Council right and
before we close I just want to make one
comment that I don't think has actually
been covered here and that is the role
of us as members here um you know that
we've had a lot of discussion about
culture uh with the council clearly the
report goes into this we have
responsibility as well and we cannot
Overlook the fact that a lot of these
problems do come back to the political
realities here you cannot have over the
last 12 years where there has been no
majority control the council there have
been eight changes of administration
there have been seven different leaders
over those 12 years three different
Chief Executives we have to take some
responsibility for that as members and
this committee very often can be I'm I'm
I'm hor I'm I'm going to say this and
I'm sure the finance team are going to
be devastated and the Auditors can be
quite dry can be quite difficult can be
quite a hard committee to follow but if
we do not do this work of supporting
officers and challenging the discussion
that we've just had has been a long one
it is great that members are challenging
and asking questions this is exactly
what this committee needs to do and I
thank everybody for the discussion um
and we coming all the way back to the
start of this this uh agenda item is
down to be approved can I have a
proposal and a second to please is down
for approval Council towning to uh
propose can I have a second to councelor
Davis are members
agreed thank you very much members um so
sticking with external audit agenda item
eight is the external audit plan 2021-22
again I have you down Chris but I'm
assuming this will be to introduce and
pass over to Grant thoron thank you
chair and I'll just pass this one
straight over to um Matt thank you yeah
thank you chair and I'll keep this from
relatively brief so this is effectively
our final audit plan for 2122 you'll
have seen a draft of this at the
previous meeting um just a part of our
process now we've progressed
significantly through the planning we
can bring you this this this final
version there is very limited change to
this to the version that was shared um
to the previous committee there was a
slight change to our draft materiality
calculation uh which is on page 138 of
the pack but the rest of it should be as
You' have seen at the previous meeting
so that's what I wanted to say on on
that at this stage happy to take any
further
questions thank you very much me members
do you have any questions on this report
no this is down for um our information
um so uh we just need to are members
happy to note the report do we need a
proposal in a second for that no no
members happy to note the
report okay um we're going to we were
potentially planning on moving the
agenda around to uh when we have the
cyber security update but we are going
to stick with the uh with the numbers so
we're going to go to agenda item 9
quarterly internal audit report and uh
Chris I believe you're reporting this CU
sment is not
available thank you thank you chair good
evening members um if I could take you
please members to page 149 of the agenda
pack and the report before you is the
summarize summary of work that's been
able to be completed and finalized with
management uh for the last quarter in
fact it's been quite a short interval
since our last um meeting um the details
on page 153 in the table highlight uh
the three pieces of work that were
concluded in time with management to be
included within the pack and we've heard
quite a bit of uh talk this evening um
around a number of um lower level
Assurance reports coming forward so it's
it's pleasing to show you the table with
a substantial opinion and two
substantial opinions and a split opinion
really with the limited um the work with
the hous and benefit testing that we
undertake um has got not applicable
against it we don't provide an assurance
opinion because we're doing uh a random
set of tests to support the subsidy
claim and the early work it's kind of
like a an early um like a litmus test
really as the year goes through we pick
the samples to see how how the year end
might look um so there's no Assurance on
that one but you'll see that we had some
good results with the testing there so
the only area really to highlight from
the work there and the table shows you
there the number of um critical high
medium and low recommendations that
we've made as well within those reports
is Page um paragraph
2.3.2 and that highlights this the
executive summary for the area with
partially limited Assurance the report
itself was split really between the
planning um side of matters um which had
a reasonable assurance and for the
section 106 uh agreements um which had a
limited Assurance so we split the
Assurance there the action plan has been
agreed with management and the
management response is shown there well
that the bottom of page 156 over to
157 and they are highlighting that good
progress has already been made in
delivering the agreed actions so there
are 15 recommendations in total eight
with high priority three with medium and
four with
low um so of course members we will be
bringing our independently tested
progress report back in due course but
it's nice to have the management
response confirming that's moving
forward and a lot of that hinge is on
that new post being recruited to and
those things that we were looking to see
being done
there moving through the report um to
page 153 paragraph 3 details the
progress report s and again noting uh
the the comment before about project
management and contract management is
really wouldd like to draw your
attention there to the good progress
being made on the plan maintenance and
contract management there so now members
seeing there are no outstanding
recommendations there and it's now
assessed as reasonable Assurance that's
really good progress in a short period
of time for you um in fact there are
virtually no
I got it in front of me now there no
recommendations outstanding at all in
all of those pieces of work that we've
undertaken I think you know we've just
heard from the previous report what is
it you're expecting to be done and by
when and these action plans are exactly
the thing that you want to see moving on
and when we come back it's every audit
is a snapshot in time but when we're
bringing news back to you like this that
is a clear clear message that said uh
fieldwork has been completed on on a
couple of other progress reports but due
to delays with the client they've been
unable to be included in tonight's
agenda um we will be obviously now
looking to bring those progress reports
to you to the next meeting uh I say next
meeting there may be an extraordinary
meeting so it'll be the next regular
meeting which will be probably the March
meeting um so looking at the table um of
outstanding recomend of of of audits
with lower levels assurance that are yet
to be followed up which is on
page 165 um I will be making some
changes to the dates there uh another
matter that we've heard quite a bit
about already in tonight's agenda um in
terms of progress and what's happening
is is related to the timing of the birth
405 follow-up review we had originally
planned to undertake that in December um
the report of course came to Council in
March and the agreed action plan
obviously had some due dates um agreed
in it um I can obviously update you as
you've already heard that the council
has now uh recruited rooted to the
resources there they've brought in some
um some specialist uh um skills to help
with the project management framework
and the training and all of those key
recommendations made within that report
so I wanted to highlight that there will
be a delay in me undertaking that work
it's sensible to do so if I did it today
it'll just be the same as it was when we
last looked um there won't be any uh
evidence of any change for me to test
and independently report back that it's
in and it's embedded it's working well
that so that said I don't I don't even
think it's likely that we will have
undertaken that work by March to report
to you in the March report um so I think
we just need to keep that one on that on
that um chart remind members in the
meantime you are tolerating the risks of
those um actions not having been
completed but I know you're well aware
of that but I I need to just draw your
attention to
it so moving through the rest of the
report we uh include our balance
scorecard of um performance indicators I
did have the figures um included to the
end of um September to the to the end of
quarter 2 of course by the end of the of
this month will be the end of quarter 3
um I have no concerns about resources to
the end of December but I do need to let
the committee know that we've sadly
received a resignation from one of our
Auditors who sought promotion away from
local government entirely actually um so
we will have a vacancy we have our
advert has gone live today or this on
Monday um so it really depends on how
long we are uh in that period of vacancy
so how badly that impacts our audit plan
um and plan completion we will look if
it's going to be lengthy we'll obviously
be looking to back fill and buy some
contractor days in to try and keep the
plan days high I think we're probably
targeted to achieve
98% um to the end based on the current
resources so obviously I'll be reporting
in March if there's been any really
significant impact but we're we're well
on target as to the end of quarter
three the report before your members is
to be uh received and I'm happy to take
any questions you may wish to raise
thank
you thank you very much um Christine um
there's a point I want to make thank
first of all great to see the progress
that's being made and um it echoes um I
spoke at cabinet recently about this
about the number of limited no
assurances and there is a real Focus
coming from officers and from the
cabinet to look into this so we've had
reports recently that showed um areas of
concern around equality and diversity
around health and safety and I'm glad to
see that there is progress taking place
on those including the establishment of
a cabinet Advisory Group around equality
and diversity so that's promising to see
one matter that you you rais and we've
had some correspondences about is about
the reporting to East Kent um ICT which
was obviously we had uh we we were
trying to tie this together with an
update it was originally on the agenda
from um head of East Kent and one of the
things that um Chris ingred and I were
working out is to try and tie together
three topics of discussion the risk
register where cyber security is our top
risk an internal audit update um with
recommendations and a management
response and an update from um the
technical Specialists about what was
going on that has not happened tonight
but that is the reason why we'll be
looking to have an extraordinary meeting
because as I understand it there is a um
in impending uh milestone of the 1st of
April when changes are going to be made
so when our meeting comes in March it
may be too late for members to have some
input and oversight of some of the
outstanding recommendations so Chris I
don't know if you want before we take
member question if you just want to
address that I think you just no you
summed that up perfectly um uh
Christine's team have done the vast
majority of the field work it's been
draft for a little while so um we're
just waiting for uh Management's
response to that to be pulled together I
believe the report's already gone to DOA
committee is due to go to doa's
committee soon um because DOA canbury
and than have a shared um cyber security
team so so lots of the findings that
have been found there will also be
present in thanet um um so we want to
get that uh report to committee as soon
as possible but as the chair rightly
said that shared service has been
disaggregated and it comes back in house
on the 1st of April so it's I think it's
really important that the committee has
sight of the um the the internal audit
Finance report and has that update from
the head of ICT from Dan Evans at the
same time in a timely manner as well
that allows you to actually make um
timely meaningful comments on any of the
issues that are presented in that
internal audit before the services
disaggregated and brought back in in
house so look out for that meeting we'll
try and find uh a date that works for
every No Doubt um knowing uh the
officers there may be additional agenda
items that get slipped in um I think
we're already anticipating a couple but
hopefully we'll keep it quite a focus
meeting councelor
Garner thank you and thank you Christine
for the report I want to I'd like to ask
about the uh the report part of the
report that covers section
106 and the processes around section 106
is since becoming a counselor for and a
half years ago and um this has been an
area cuz I'm I'm I'm on the planning
committee I have been since I've been a
counselor but section 106 is one of the
areas that has caused me a lot of
frustration and a lot of
disappointment in that I've found it
incredibly difficult and I think as
you've partly highlighted to find out
anything about what what happened
happens with section 106 agreements here
it's almost impossible to find out
details of all the section 106
agreements any of them whether and
progress made against section 106
agreements whether monies have
been collected as promised when trigger
points have been reached and then
whether whether they've then been
appropriately spent on the areas that
they should have been spent on I I mean
I
have sorry I won't go on but I do have
one one
experience for when I was a very new
counselor chasing up about Playgrounds
in my
Wards I found out that there was 150,000
have been sitting in an account for
nearly three years to to upgrade all of
the playgrounds in boo stairs I'm not
quite sure what would have happened if I
or anyone else hadn't have caused a
little bit of a fuss about it but in the
end the playgrounds got replaced so I am
looking forward to the um
reports been produced for 1920 2021 2122
2223 and hoping that they do contain a
complete audit trail of all of the
section 10c six agreements the evidence
of all of the any monies that have been
collect Ed and evidence of how they've
all been spent because I'm I suspect
there will be a a few um surprises that
we might want to have a good look at um
I'm I I'm slightly puzzled that I I'm
sure the
other or maybe they're not but the other
districts within East Kent so do DOA
Canter City and poon high do how do they
how are they measuring up with their
section 106 agreements would you say
that councelors on each of
those in each of those districts are
equally as frustrated and disappointed
when they want to find out details about
any of their section 106
agreements and we talked about learning
from other councils what can we learn
from
them thank you Council gner Christine do
you want to come in on that thank you
chair I think there hasn't been the time
in my career when we've audited section
106 and not had a number of
recommendations around that whole audit
Trail
reconciliation um whether there's RPI
whether they index linked all of the and
I I I wonder just musing whether it's
one of those um functions that does
become a bit siloed across across
professions so um I think this post that
you've um recruited to here will be very
key in having that oversight view of
them um there's clearly a timing delay
isn't there from the point of agreeing
one when it the dirt hasn't even been
dug in the ground to sometime in the
future when the trigger points reached
and as you rightly say then how it's
allocated um and without excellent
records things can be lost every time
we've tried to reconcile in the past
we've always found some that are on some
sheets and not on other sheets so it's
it's a it's a wonderful opportunity here
to to get this right now um but yeah I I
would say we've always had a number of
recommendations in this area each time
we've audited
it just say because it is an area that
members of the public are are interested
in and it affects them a lot especially
when we have a number of planning
applications that a number of residents
are not happy with or they they make
objections to and one of the things they
do see well actually when delivering
this this development you will also get
this amount of money for for hospitals
you will also get this amount of money
for playgrounds and this amount so they
want to be see seeing that and I I know
I'm sure others do a number of residents
contact me about well when are we going
to see any of this you know going back
to planning applications three or four
years ago so it would be nice for us all
to be readily armed with facts about
this has been delivered this is what
you're getting and it just makes it a
lot a lot easier for residents to accept
things thank you thank you councelor
Garner um I've got councelor manners and
councelor Davis councelor
manners thanks ch um I'm just uh
responding to what councilor Garner has
just said um and it it is quite was very
preent what he had to say about section
106 money uh at recent uh the last
Council when Jackie Bakers was on the
agenda it was only an intervention from
a counselor John Davis uh where the
section 106 money was found down the
back of the sofa um it seemed pretty
obvious that it' been forgotten about um
so having a a proper register of 106 um
commitments would would be very very
useful I think thank you if I can just
come in on that point because obviously
Jackie Bakers is in the ward that I
represent in North Northwood and uh it's
been quite a Focus for us I can assure
you that that money was not down the
back of sofa in fact today uh a master
plan for Jackie Bakers was actually
published on the agenda for overview and
scrutiny includes quite an investment
from the council and there was a report
produced by external Consultants back in
March actually covered those figures so
I am grateful councelor Davis for his
question and I believe there was an foi
from or a request put into the Press
office from one of the local papers
which brought that money up but I can
assure you that figure was not lost down
the back of a soap and was fact Ed in
when they were planning Jackie Bakers by
take the point councelor
Davis hopefully it wasn't sitting on
something else down the back of the sofa
that stopped to getting lost so um I
just wanted to confirm with because 106
is a is a is a big issue um I know for
instance that cliffsend Parish Council
are having a lot of frustrations with
trying to get answers because Cliff
cen's got a 50% increase in its size not
a penny spent um in fact tomorrow
morning at 9:15 we're visiting a site
that's running on to the end of its time
frame my understanding is that the
council is or has recruited a specific
officer to manage 106 monies and so on
is that the case or where are we at with
it Chris would you be able to respond to
that think that was in the budget Matt's
probably better place to answer that one
than I'm it's actually covered in the
report the post has been recruited
to okay members as no uh changes have
been uh um proposed to the 2023 24
internal audit this is down for
receiving it and noting it um our
members um happy to receive the report
and note it can have a proposer in a
seconder councelor Davis proposed
councelor Garner second did um all
members agreed thank you very much uh
moving on to agenda item 10 we have the
audit committee Assurance statement um
Chris would you like to introduce the
report thank you I'll try and keep this
one brief um as I appreciate it's been a
long meeting already and there's a
couple of still um quite meaty
substantive items left on the agenda so
the purpose of this um document is
effectively to try and improve or at
least demonstrate effective two-way
communication between the council's
exteral Auditors who who were with us
earlier and the governance and audit
committee so um Annex 2 actually sets
out the response to the questions the
rest of it just um uh addressing around
the document I think so you see in the
document sets out under various
different headings General inquiries of
management fraud laws and rs Rel related
parties easy for me to say going concern
and accounting estimates um I won't go
through all of them because there's
quite a lot of detail in there but I
think probably the most um uh poignant
and important one to draw your attention
to is sorry I'm working off a different
set of pages to the full agenda pack um
but page 10 of this of of annex 2 on the
fraud risk assessment the Third question
there where we did um Identify some
fraud um through a
whistleblowing um uh whistleblowing
activity an officer um um identified
something it was um reported to internal
audit and actually investigate as part
of their audit on the um planned
maintenance
audit um as part of that you can see we
then uh undertook some remeasurement of
the work what had had happened would
been we the long and short of it we've
been charged for uh external decorations
and um uh rendering on properties that
did not have render um so there was um a
little bit more than sharp practice um
we had those remeasured we recovered the
money through outstanding invoices that
are already um due on the system so we
weren't exposed to any sort of
overcharging and it was reported through
the sort of standard processes I think
it was actually Matt that did the
reporting himself um through to uh the
police um my understanding the latest
position of the police weren't intended
to take any further action due to the
size of the fraud was not considered
significant enough um that's the main
part of it the rest of it's fairly s
procedural stuff that you would see in a
year byye um sort of standard reporting
of of these types of um issues CU they
talk about the type of controls that we
have in place to report these things to
you what we would typically do is
actually I myself well usually Matt
would write this um and we would bring
this to the chair of the committee in
and run it um past them as chair to sign
it off rather than bring it to the full
committee that's one of the
recommendations but obviously happy to
take questions on that and uh the
committee have may have different views
as to whether they wish to see this uh
document in
future do your members have any comments
or questions is there two
recommendations down that we note and
approve the responses and that in the
future this is delegated to the1 officer
and myself in consultation with myself
to detail these uh can I have a proposal
in a second for the recommendation of
councelor Pacman seconded by councelor
briter our members agreed agreed thank
you very much um we are now on to agenda
item 11 uh risk management I have Amy
down to um go through this report um Amy
would you be happy if I just made a
comment first just um from from the
discussions we had you will notice there
is a change to the report this time and
it is at my request and we agreed it at
the Chairman's briefing every meeting
we've had on the list the key risks and
then we've had supplementary documents
showing emerging risks future risks I
think those are important for us to note
from time to time but there is a lot of
information in there and those risks
because of the way they're scored um are
obviously much lower priority than some
of the larger risks so at previous
committees that I've noticed we don't
talk about cyber security and the
economic environment the things that
will actually Impact Services we will
talk about a much smaller risk um that
may be emerging people are concerned
about but we shouldn't be talking about
it every committee so as a balance we'll
be having the main risk register coming
every committee and then twice a year we
will have those emerging in future risks
um just so then our we are Focus as a
commit committee on those key risks but
members will be given an opportunity to
look at those emerging and future risks
but just not at every meeting so poies
Amy over to you to introduce the report
thank you um thank you chair so this
report provides the governor and audit
committee with a quarterly review of the
corporate risks um so just before I go
into the risk scoring as you can all see
on page seven I would like to just take
a few moments to give members some
background information and also an
update on our current progress so as you
can probably see the strategy does
Define corporate risks as those which
impact across the whole Council and that
is um exactly what we just been talking
about these are the huge risk that are
from the bottom upwards through service
planning and continuous review during
year this is how they're identified
operational risks can be also escalated
into larger corporate risk as we know um
and this is dependent on the evaluation
of the risk and threat discussions with
the senior management team so this
strategy to demands that the risks are
to be assessed by the corporate
management team and by the governance
and audit committee on a regular basis
so just to give a bit of background and
I know there are a couple of counselors
here that were here last year when we
changed the strategy but there's a lot
of new faces as well this year so um the
previous policy had been in place for
some time um I believe it was about
2019 um and because of that we did run
the risk if you excuse the pun of it
becoming a tick boox exercise and it was
with little value in the end so we
wereing for officers and members to
become engaged in Risk Management to
become proactive um and as a local
Authority rather than just reacting when
risk occurred actually re proactively
dealing with the risk before they
actually started so this was then
approved at the governance and audit
committee on the 27th of July last year
so consequently we are in the process of
transitioning to operating under the new
risk management strategy we're
constantly looking at the way that we
approach this not just with it with you
guys but also with our staff with the
managers anybody that feeds into the
risk registers because that's the bottom
up approach um so there is a new way of
monitoring evaluating and Reporting the
risk substantial progress has been made
during this risk reporting cycle I can
honestly tell you when I first started
doing risk registers the response rate
was about 10% of them coming back we
looked to about 90 to 95% if not 100% on
every risk cycle now and that really
shows the engagement that we've actually
achieved during this process so um so
work has already started as well and I
know that council scob is already sorry
the chairs already said that we have the
annex risk which we won't go into this
time we'll save a bit excitement for the
March meeting instead um so so as I said
we've started to undertaking reporting
to the committee and applying the
framework to the higher score in
corporate risks which is what we have go
on to have a look in a minute and that's
in section 4 and I believe on your
documents that might be page seven
um and in the future we're also looking
to apply some graphical illustrations
and also risk management Journey so
showing you where the risk has come from
where is it and where do we want it to
go to and that really encompasses this
whole new way of dealing with risk
management so if we go down to page
seven and we look at the table of the
large corporate risks and these are the
corporate risks that you can see every
governance and audit committee this is
what we'll present to you so each
corporate risk is the responsibility of
a member of CMT and they manage risk man
and they manage the risk mitigation
plans with the aim of reducing the
likelihood of each risk to a manageable
level so that gives you a risk appetite
what do we actually want to take on um
as time moves on the external
environment changes and this can have an
impact on the effectiveness of these
medications so we need to be we need to
be agile we need to make sure that we
move with the risk medications as well
um and just to just to um remind as well
it's more difficult to take action to
reduce the impact of a risk than is the
likelihood it's easier for us to stop
something from happening than rather to
make it less worse um so that just gives
you a brief overview on our risk
management how we're going to be
presenting this going forward and if we
do look at the scoring mechanism um we
will see that most of them are remain
the same and I think that goes to prove
you know sometimes they do remain
relatively high but we do have a
reduction under EPC requirements um so
that's pretty much the risk management
strategy and the risk management
report thank you very much
um one um one comment before we open up
to questions from Members is is it
possible that we could potentially
arrange some training for members around
risk management before one of the next
meetings I think that would be quite
useful I would absolutely love that that
I actually would um you know because to
have everybody engaged is what risk
management is about
you know if everybody knows what they're
doing that's what it's all about and
this is how we deal with risk from the
top downwards and bottom upwards so yes
I'd love that and obviously mandatory
for all
members
Chris I just want to say Amy's
enthusiasm for this is genuine and I
think a lot of credit goes to Amy with
the sort of risk management is probably
up there with treasury management with
being one of the driest subjects that
officers have to come across but her
enthusiasm for it is infectious and that
really has generated that buy in from
offices if you had someone that was
coming at it with a very monotone it's
time to do your risk management I don't
think we'd have the same sort of
Engagement so a credit is due to Amy on
that I'm sure she'll make the training
very fun and engaging I will I
promise Council
toy i' just like to say Amy I'm
delighted to see you back in the chamber
and I wish you well for the
future um so I I've got a a couple of um
questions on the risk register
um obviously we are hoping to arrange an
ex ear meeting to talk about um the risk
of cyber security and a potential Cyber
attack um and we've discussed at
previous last two meetings this
issue I I would like to see when we come
back in
January more granularity of detail
around these risks because I think
looking at local government sector and
looking at the potential risk profile of
the council and the fact that we're
going through a
change I cannot see how Cyber attack can
be on the same level as some of those
other risks and it feels like it's about
to heighten yeah and it feels like I
haven't seen the contents of the audit
report I don't know what um updates
we're going to get but um having been
worked in cyber security for nearly a
decade now looking at the major failings
of private businesses that put
significant investment into it over a
number of years and still have holes I
would imagine an organization that's
gone through the changes that thanet has
in the last 5 years I would imagine that
the security procedures are not where we
would hope they would be I I I
completely accept that um the economic
environment um the potential impacts of
the environment act um the changes we
have to make to Net Zero are
substantial risk for the council I would
challenge quite hard whether they have
the ability to Impact Services and
impact residents of the speed that a
Cyber attack could it's very far
reaching yeah and the the bit that I
don't have visibility of which I hope we
will get after the extraordinary meeting
is what the mitigations look like
because to have something scored so high
but still be on a par with other risks
the mitigations would have to be very
very good and I'm getting the sense that
they may not be where they want to be so
I I don't know what that looks like but
if if we are having this discussion in
January about cyber security I would
like the risk register to be part of
that and I would like to understand some
of the mitigations that we're doing
because they are not there then my view
would be that this committee should be
flagging that up to Cabinet who I'm sure
are already aware and working on this
because the potential impact to our
residen is is too
high thank you ch yeah yes I've taken
that on board thank you um and the the
second the second issue relates to a
report we've had earlier and the
comments that members have made um if
you look at the reports a year ago one
of the top risks was related to
governance and decision making and
within two meetings that had dropped
from being the top risk to not even
being in the key risks now I think we
all agreed we're going in the right
right um on the right route again I
would question I would be interested
whether we have been a little bit too
quick to downgrade that risk I can see
that the immediate impact is down but
for it not to be even included on the
key RIS we're talking about I understand
that it's still in some of those annexes
we had it may be
premature especially because if you had
another governance issue now that's
layered on what's happened before I
think the cumulative impact of that to
the reputation of the council and the
questions that will be raised about the
decision making process would still
remain high so e even though I would
accept that the immediate um potential
for that risk to be continue to impact
in the council I would question whether
it's on that and and and actually from
the committee's perspective I mean I'm
speaking I'd be interested in members
thoughts if you drop it down it sort of
goes off the agenda slightly and a risk
like that that disrupted the council
that we're now having reports where
you've got three years of um annual
reports coming back that have red
ratings on them I just wonder whether
that's a little bit
premature yes thank you J can I pass
that to you gra thank you absolutely um
so yes very good point in terms of um it
dropping off and being out of sort of um
The Mind's Eye so to speak out of sight
out out of mind it would have been on
that Annex um but for the reasons
obviously that we've have been discussed
we're going to streamline the reporting
on that
um I think the go there there's two
risks on there from a recollection that
were governance related firstly one
around political stewardship because as
you said earlier the amount of change in
sort of control and uh leadership of the
council and no an overall control um
situation the council found itself in
that presented um a risk itself I mean
certainly during the last Council we you
know was a period of time where we had
sort of three Council leaders in a very
short space of time we're in a different
situation now and actually even at the
tail end of the last Council I think
there was a clear demonstration that the
when there wasn't overall control there
was really good cross-party working
relationships that definitely improved
was my view over the period of the
council the last Council um the other
one and so I think that's that's
legitimate for that to be um off the
other one is a fair point as to whether
um yeah the the the immediate the impact
the immediate impact of the risk that we
were facing and dealing with all the
costs associated and the disruption
associate with the previous corporate
management team that's been dealt with
but there there is clearly still a risk
that something could happen like that
again in the
future I hope nothing that's comparable
to that cuz I think it was quite a
unique set of circumstances that we had
to attend to um but nonetheless I think
is you know and grid and I were saying
earlier when we speaking some of the
items there's still work to be done to
improve some of the government's
Arrangements at the council but I don't
feel the the same magnitude in terms of
if you're talking like if you compare
that to a Cyber attack we're talking um
um things that we know we need to
improve improve but won't necess have
reputational damage that would see us in
the you know the national press or would
have us um Services you know um
Financial costs that getting towards
seven figure sum so there could be
governance issues we know we've not
cracked it yet but the impact isn't
severe enough I feel at the moment for
it to be on that um corporate risk
register but it's still very much and
think that it's on that Annex even
though we're not bringing it to the
committee there's still things that we
Monitor and we talk about it will go
through our corporate management team um
Amy and I will have discussions about it
as well so it is there
um I suppose to conclude we're certainly
not resting on our Laurels even if it's
not on in this reports okay I think that
gives me some Assurance on that one that
at least we're going to monitor it um
and you
know don't members agree with that
councilor Garner come in please yeah I
do maybe at the next full meeting not
not extraordinary meeting that element
of the annex could come on the report to
to to committee um I did just want to
ask one minor question about the
reporting CC
requirements has pleasingly gone down
from 12 to
4: um so I assume that that should
shouldn't be read
anymore no that's correct Council Garner
and we leave it on the report just for
one C cycle so you can see um the change
and that will drop off on the next um
risk
report
any other comments or questions from
Members um so this report is down for
information um and I hopefully when we
have the extraordinary meeting my
comments around cyber security can be
picked up by officers but our members
happy to note the report y agreed okay
final agenda item thanet Lottery update
um we have uh Chris can you please
provide us with your report thank you um
yes last item to get through so thank
you uh councilors for your patient and
contribution so far appreciate there's
been already be some um discussion on
this item so far into in previous um
papers that we've discussed so the
purpose of bringing this item um at this
time is the thanet lottery was
audited um back in
2022 and it was um classified as as
having no assurance the audit um there
were 14 sort of recommendations at that
point in time and management actions
needed to address it however when the
followup was undertaken in February 2023
you can see that only six of those had
been implemented and there was still
eight outstanding with meant that it was
still no Assurance so given that we'
gone through that cycle the committee
had asked for a subsequent update and um
which said need to leave a little period
of time from February to allow for some
of those things to uh be
implemented
um in terms of I I won't speak to them
all but I'll go through some of the uh
critical and higher recommendations so
the first one you can see in the
reporters around um policies that has
been um partially partially implemented
and that um the corporate management
team have had sight of revised policies
but they haven't actually been form
adopted yet so um we've got a new policy
manager so that role has been vacant for
a little while they'll be starting with
us next month and this um the formal
adoption of those policies will be
allocated to that officer to uh
Implement those and get them promoted
and publicized accordingly so we
anticipate that recommendation will be
fully implemented by February of next
year the next recommendation which I
think is probably the one of most
interest uh to the committee is around
the the allocation of actual the funds
that we've built up so far um as it's
been referred to earlier the uh the plan
is that the process for bidding to the
funds will be Amalgamated with the uh
shared Prosperity fund bidding process
um so again that that is partially
implemented because we have a plan but
there are still things that we need to
do I've note there's been some comments
and concerns around member involvement
on that panel the those are noted um my
response to to that appreciate it's not
been mentioned on that item would be I
would be very wary of
um um having members on a panel to
allocate grants with at that level of of
allocation we're talking 1 to
5,000 without having a very uh tight
terms of reference in terms of what the
role of members were in that because
um it we're looking to have have a
criteria scoring criteria in place where
there should be less room for
subjectivity which could posst possibly
open the council up to challenge if
things would be seen to be allocated on
political or other means of allocation
so it's something that can be discussed
but my my initial Instinct would be to
actually follow a framework that is
based on a scoring uh Criterion that
doesn't mean that can't you know that
would be done behind closed doors that
should still be very transparent and
open process where we can see and
determine how those um those scores have
been allocated and the fundings have
been awarded um the next one uh that
I'll talk to is the scheme of
delegations this one has been
implemented this has gone through um I
can't remember which committee it went
to it might have been uh constitutional
review working party scheme delegation
one of one of the more Council sorry ing
I think it was before your time so don't
know why my Bo you um the final one is
training so there was um this again has
been partially implemented I have to put
my hand up I've not completed all the
training on this there's a lot of
e-learning e-learning is not my favorite
thing to do and I've got a long list of
than Lotto related e-learning still to
do um the rest are medium
recommendations so I won't talk to those
but I'm happy to take questions on them
so to conclude of those eight that were
still outstanding in February we've de
dealt with four of them so I feel that
those four can be discharged made some
progress with the others but they're
only partially implemented so of still
another four outstanding that need to be
dealt
with thank you very much um I have
Council maners but I just want to make a
a comment myself with that so council
maners is happy with that um this I this
report I think um shows why it's
important that we keep these things on
the agenda so it's something that you
and I have discussed at length in the
past about these reports but I remember
when I first became chair of GNA and
challenging you know why there were
outstanding recommendations on the lotto
and you know I think the discussion we
had was that it wasn't a priority for
the council things change and suddenly
so that that's sort of the negative you
know in a way that I think we need to
make sure that all recommendations
regardless of whether they're priority
or not for us now should be pushed the
the positive is I think this is a very
good report um just um members I know
there's I understand from comments said
made before there are some concerns
around it to be clear this is down for
information we're not a decision maker
on this we are noting the contents of
the update from the management response
so Council maners please thank you will
um I'm actually really pleased to see
this on the agenda um and I think it it
shows how far the council has come in
the last two years um from absolute no
hope no confidence with the gaming
commission to now we might be on the
cusp of having a functioning Lottery
that might generate some revenue for
local community causes so you know that
that's very very commendable and I'm
very pleased to see it um I am concerned
that given what's been said this evening
about governance and the progress that's
been made on that that we are mindful to
include members and I tell I do note
what what Chris is saying um with the
strictures that that that relate to
political involvement possible buers and
so on but then that is the role of the
officers to to build a framework within
which the members can operate not to
actually um Take Over Control of of
every aspect of of running something um
and I would like to see more
participation from members uh
facilitated guarded watched over by the
officers who we believe obviously are
competent to to create framework for
that to happen um I am concerned that
the idea of having a point scoring
system which is very dry and I
appreciate that's a very objective way
of um processing applications but it's
also you know you think about where we
want this money to go the the take an
example the the the scout master who
who's probably holding down a job got a
couple of kids at home runs the Thursday
evening Scouts group proba got a leaky
roof and he wants to get his roof fixed
and probably hasn't got time to sit
through and Wade through a whole process
which we know will be convoluted and
geared towards people who are able to
employ full-time on the payroll bid
writers and we'll end up with a another
money go around where important
Community funding ends up in the hands
of those who least need it uh that's my
concern and that's why I would like to
see member involvement um it just seems
to deliver a better result and also it
would seem to be within the aim of this
uh committee to ensure uh proper
governance thank
you councelor
Davis thank you chair um I think
following through on uh the points I'd
like to make is the fact that
um member oversight of this entire Pro
process and and and you know we can call
it whatever word we want is utterly
vital we still have four outstanding
issues this so in terms of if we tick
them off as equivalent issues we're 50%
of the way through the process since
February last week at a meeting that
members were actively precluded from
attending to ensure no no transparency
in my opinion officers of this Council
are discussed with Community groups
represent atives and those charged by
the parish councils to Lia with them
about how they were going to be invite
or they were inviting applications and
so on we're nowhere near ready to invite
applications for lottery funding and
things because from the sound of it
we're nowhere near launch we might be in
the scale of things but this is exactly
why member involvement is vital because
we have certain officers that I believe
are just getting far too carried away
with themselves and they think that you
know the Del delated Authority is
without it's like the debark of bid
writing for up to 20,000 from the um uh
the shared Prosperity fund that's
apparently now officers decided with no
input from the members that people can
apply for up to £20,000 but in order to
do that they have to appoint a bid
writer at a cost of
£1,500 so they then have to apply for a
,500 chunk out of the government money
that's been provided to help the
community in order to fill in a form of
their own
design it's just people inventing jobs
you know Sir Humphrey couldn't make this
up it's an absolute F and members must
be involved at the core in order to
ensure good governance
because in fact I've seen another email
um from one of the administrators of
this program to an elected member
telling them that they would be
reviewing how elected members would deal
with the members of the public I don't
know who these people think they are
they you know there's constitutional
issues here and the rights of an elected
member we are the bridge to the
community the officers are there to
implement policy as agreed by cabinet
and it and its cascad um delegated
bodies they are there to act within a
set of parameters not to make it up as
they go along and to invent money go
rounds that to be quite Frank I'd ask
who the who the bid writers are that are
going to benefit from 1, 1500 quid on
every application it's absolutely
obscene and I think this Council has to
take a stance to protect the interests
of the public Pur because it's being
paid fast and loose here and to actually
announce at a conference and record and
invite people to apply for lottery
funding when it's quite clear tonight
that we are not in a position yet to
proceed with it is nothing short than
it's exactly why members have to be
involved otherwise we've got
misinformation and who takes the Flack
for it the members and the and the
authority I'm sorry to be quite so ranty
on this but it's absolutely vital is
councelor Davis you you are passionate
about this what I what I think before I
sort of bring in councelor farqi and
councelor Madness I just want to dissect
some of the challenges Edge to make sure
I'm understanding where it fits in with
this committee because some of the stuff
you've mentioned is obviously concerns
around a particular officer and I mean I
will or officers officers I don't think
it's appropriate at all that this
committee has discussion of those um if
you have concerns there is a process to
be raised and I'm I'm sure the
monitoring officer can advise of that
and I don't know if you want to come in
at that point or or and and just on
another couple of related points around
member engagement it's a completely Fair
comment coming from I was on Kent County
Council where members actually gave out
grants I can tell you that process
itself was not great either um I think
there there is no perfect process um and
I would have just as much concerns about
members Distributing funds in their
Wards to organizations they were chummy
with or organizations they'd worked with
actually having a much more independent
process from where you had bids coming
in and they were evaluated against a
criteria has its merits as well so but I
I recognize there's an opinion there in
terms of the specific point for this
committee about the assurances around
the thanet lotto I think you are right
there are things outstanding and I guess
the the the response I would say is
let's make sure and if if um Chris
blandau is happy with this let's make
sure we get a follow-up report to the
next Committee in March and hopefully we
will see that all of those
recommendations are closed out I think
that's the appropriate part for for this
point um for this committee I apologize
so I'm just going to bring in ingri on
that that point and then maybe Chris
talk specifically about the next meeting
but thank you so just in relation to any
concerns that you've got about Staffing
obviously it's really important that
they're addressed through the proper
procedures which is obviously with a
relevant director um and or with HR if
there are issues in relation to any kind
of Standards issues any code of conduct
issues obviously bring them to my
attention if there's any constitutional
impropriety as I said before bring that
to my attention so that's what I'd say
about concerns in relation to Staffing
and it's really really important that
those are addressed and that's all about
improving the council improving the
culture in improving member officer
relations and I think those things
really mustn't be left so I'd really
urge you to do that and obviously as I
said bring any issues in relation to
constitutional impropriety or you know
bring them to my attention I absolutely
undertake to um look into those what i'
say in relation to um uh I don't know
the ins and outs of the framework for um
deciding funding I'm OB I've obviously
read the report I've commented on the
report but what I do know is that any
system should and you know we are bound
to we've we're Bound by the public
sector equality Duty and any system
needs to consider equalities in in terms
of a scoring in terms of the way it's
set up and designed and I knowe what you
say I don't I don't have a particular
view in relation to member involvement
or not but what I do have a view about
is that we we we must be bound by our
public sector equality duties and any
process and any system shouldn't be
discriminating against um any community
group or those that are
socioeconomically more advantaged than
others so that that that's something
that we must um make sure that there are
measures in place to protect
from I'm going to bring Chris in and
then I do have councelor faruki
councelor manners and councelor Bry
Chris uh yes happy to bring a report
back to um hopefully conclude that all
the recommendations have been uh
discharged uh our March committee um
what would say in this instance we've
obviously accepted the recommendation
ations but it's not always the case that
we would accept all the recommendations
that are put um To Us by internal I
would say it is largely the case that we
do but in some instances we will push
back because um internal order are
making a recommendation around the
controls that should be in place to
reduce a certain risk and it might be
decision that we've taken do you know
what actually we're going to accept that
risk or we you know we're going to uh
we're not going to take that action
because this is the consequences that um
attachment not something that are either
a very high priority or we can resource
it and we determined it's something
we're going to address in another way
and this instance we've clearly accepted
all the recommendations um so through
the passage of time and we'll be aiming
for March report come back and with a
fair wind it will all um be looking fine
and dandy thank you Chris I think you've
heard strong views from a couple of
members so I think we would want to see
progress on that councelor
faruki um thank you very much for the
the um for the report I think it says a
lot about the um transparency of the
process which I think is really
appreciated um especially given um some
of the historical issues that have been
mentioned here I'd like to make a
Counterpoint actually to my um counselor
colleagues um comments which are you
know they're very passionate plea for a
more devolved member-led Council I think
I have some concerns about I understand
um why you're making this plea I have
feeling that um that speech wasn't just
for us but it was for the wider public
who may also be paying attention to this
but um I do have some concerns that in
ter trying to devolve to member Le
Council you actually risk um some of the
democratic process which are actually
purporting to correct one of which is
that we are risking perhaps looking at
things which are popular rather than
thing and judging things in that way and
being swayed by opinion rather than by
making judgments which are fair and
Equitable which are actually following a
due process um I I'm sure about the
evidence that it's a fair process as
well I know um perhaps inductively you
feel that it would be so but I'm unsure
if there is any evidencebased for that
it is a better and more Equitable
process and I do worry that um you may
find that decision- making could fall
along party lines and even you know I I
think that could be an issue in terms of
um policy and in terms of quick wins
when we're actually trying to make
appropriate decisions um I apologize for
not being terribly eloquent I've come
off a 12-hour shift but um I just wanted
to express this counter
point thank you very much councilor fari
I have a council
manners uh thank you for that um yeah a
couple of couple of points
um why I do believe um when we're
looking at process that member
involvement is important here
um Community funding from a lottery is
increasingly important um in
Bridging the Gap between what the
council might want to deliver and what
what's actually possible um and that's
obvious that's not that that Gap isn't
going to reduce in the near future um
and obviously we need people out there
selling this Lottery you want
ambassadors for it who are saying that
you know you should be a retailer you
should you should buy these tickets the
the money that you you know you might
win some money and you you're going to
help some good local causes so I think
it is important that we have um members
who feel part of that process um because
at the end of the day that that we've
got 50 odd people out there who are
going to be spreading the word um I am
very concerned though that um I know
what ingred has said um about having a a
process that is accessible to everyone
um we are in in the real world you know
I I I wear two hats one running a
community interest company um and I'm
not here talking about uh pitching for
funding but we want if we wanted to
organize for example a beach clean over
Christmas and give our volunteers uh a
glass of mold wine on the beach I need
to submit a risk assessment copy of my
public liability insurance uh apply for
a temporary events notice license to be
able to give away a glass of wine and if
we've got more than 20 Beach cleaners
and events license and that's the
reality of interacting with fic District
Council as a community group the burden
of
administration excludes many smaller
groups from actually doing anything and
it will exclude them from applying for
funding which is why I think we do have
to look at making sure that funding is
accessible and uh particularly for for
smaller grants um and um it is local
counselors who have their eyes and ears
to the ground who are meeting with local
um Community groups these Community
groups are very often operating outside
of office hours they you know councilors
don't go home at 5:00 where they're
where they're visiting these groups
after hours um and seeing what needs to
be done um and um again it just comes
back to having that
um basically a democratic accountability
with with the the members and trusting
them to do their jobs properly uh and we
are grown-ups um the majority of members
are stood election not for partisan
Point scoring they stood for election
because they want to improve things in
the local community irrespective of
party affiliation thanks thank you very
I I think there is an important point
and I I will come to councilor Bri but
um there is an important point in what
you said there around requirements
around insurance and risk assessment
because there are new laws coming into
place Martin's law following the
horrific events in Manchester are
putting the onus on people organizing
events or venues that have our access
accessible by the public to actually be
responsible for security and safety
because of some of the things that have
happened in the past and actually having
those emergency plans in place so I do
not think that while I you know it's
always difficult important not to to
that I I I get that but I I I would I
would say that some of the things maybe
you're seeing coming through are not the
council doing it because it's just red
tape but the law is is is going through
Parliament at the moment to change some
of those things so apologies councelor
Bri you wanted to come
in
yeah I just wanted to touch on a couple
of the points that have been made really
um I think we do need to be guarded that
we are as councilors not running the
council we are elected members um we
don't get involved in day-to-day
operations however um I would agree with
some of what council manner said in
that we know our communities better than
than it District Council officers
um by default we are the ones that go
out there we are the ones that are
working with different Community groups
in our little pockets of our little
towns um and I really think it's
important that we are as members
encouraged to act as that Comm conduit
and I I would Echo that the burden of
administration needs to be minimized
we're not talking about giving 250,000
to these groups we're talking about
giving them, 1500 quid or something so I
think we need to be really careful how
we're engaging and I think it's an
opportunity for this Council to be more
more than just a corporate entity use
the experience that Parish councils have
got Parish councils do this stuff every
single year and do it really well um
they give grants all the time so use
that experience we we know and we've
talked to the um we've talked at four
Council meetings about thanet District
Council engaging more with the town and
Parish councils um to kind of pass on
the wisdom and help with training Etc uh
give the give experience to officers at
town at town and Parish Council level it
goes both ways I think there are
probably things that town and Parish
councils are doing very very well I'm
thinking particularly of the large ones
like Ramsgate and and like broadstairs
that do very very well with Community
groups that actually nent uh nent
Community projects at thanet level could
probably tap into so I think we need to
be just be really really mindful that
we've got a lot of people in the room
right now that are very engaged with the
community do want to get involved albeit
not from an operational point so just uh
I I think we should just be very very
mindful of
that thank you very much I've got
councelor davidon and councel
right uh thank you chair I I just wanted
to clarify something I got very confused
by councelor farooqi's position because
she started talking about partisan
things this committee is nonpartisan and
is about governance and things and I
just want to be quite clear that nothing
that has been said from this side
tonight is in any way party Affiliated
or indeed playing to the crowd as she
intimated so I I I think the point and
it's the point that I made as well which
is if you Mo move to a funding model
where council is involved in like as as
Kent County Council has money will go
into groups associated with that
counselor and funding potentially go to
the political part and I think that is a
very real point and I think there is a
lot of evidence out there about it so
the point point that we both made was to
say that it's not a case that members
good officers bad there are balances on
both I was referring to the comment
about tonight's position rather than
that but but no that's why it's so
important I think that we have as broad
transparency as possible members and
officers working together and that way
you cover each other rather than this
behind closed door cabal mentality it's
a fair point um you wanted to come in
quickly yeah very it's probably um just
uh this may all be aware but it's um
it's probably not that clear in the
reports the this is the element of the
thanet lotto that when someone buys a
ticket they haven't already identified a
good cause so good causes can already um
sign up to the lottery and say um I'd
like to register as a good cause for the
lottery we have a set of criteria if
they meet it which I'd say 99 times out
of 100 they do and they're added to it
um they're not extremely prohibitive um
then when someone buys a ticket they are
able to say I want to support ex Scout
group or Y charity and the majority of
the money goes to them if someone buys a
ticket and they don't nominate a set
cuse that goes into this this pot that
the council has to allocate so it's not
that there isn't already a process in
place where good cses are registered and
they can't promote themselves because
they still have the ability to do that
this is for the um element of the
lottery fund where a purchaser of the
ticket has not decided which good cause
they want their um their their um their
ticket money to go
towards um Council right apologies for
bumping okay um I'm glad you left it
along um I kind of um I'm going to give
you an example as some most of you know
that I'm also K County counselor and I
have a pot and I think there is a
gentleman sitting in front of me called
Mr Donaldson who will say that I've had
had no problem in being partisan um I'm
holding a an amount
of grant money for for a project if he
can get it off the
ground and it does work and I'd like to
think that over the last couple of years
any money that that I've given out how
big or small have gone to people who
really need it thank you very much
councelor right councelor town thank
you go further from councilor bright and
Ms and
Davis I can't see the reason why there's
any objection to have members
involved because all it'll do is to
increase the actual understanding of
that distribution of the
money of course we all want to have our
own War to receive money but I think
we've got to be fair and say that there
is a responsibility upon ourselves to do
the correct and proper thing and I think
you officers must understand that we are
the people who actually go out into the
community find out what they need and we
put their case forward whether we are
successful in obtaining that money or
not is neither here nor there but at
least we have an answer to the public to
say we tried and if we don't try and we
not a part of that that makeup then I
think you know where the ones are going
to be criticized the officers never get
criticized because they are not in the
public domain so I believe that that we
should have a representation in the that
decision making and and I think you
ought to trust us as members thank you
thank you and then finally councelor Bri
to ask a question yeah it's just a
really specific one this fund is
available to groups from across stet or
is it only in specific areas no across
the whole District thank
you so members this was the most debated
item and it is down for
information so are we happy to note the
report thank you very much um that
brings us to the end of the meeting um I
bet you're all very glad that we don't
have another hour hours worth of cyber
security chat right now we'll save that
for after the New Year have a good
Christmas everybody and we will see you
at the next governance audit meeting in
the new
year
for